But last time you guys stopped on the island of freefield to get some
repairs for your ship as well as get a cage for the saber tooth as it's been chewing away
the part where it was kept because it just made of wood so you have the cage done for the saber tooth and
you have gotten the ship repaired you have
50 million store credit for
the
Bramble and brothers ship ride company and
You have departed from the island of freefield and you're on your way to the island that
You were you had the
logposts for that piece from the
warland reserve shop
As you're traveling it's the
morning of
What is everyone doing right now?
Cooking okay
office
Probably just sitting outside
Okay
Nothing seems to be out of sword this morning
Baptist you have not woken up yet the fight from
Last night was really heavy on you you had some damage so you're still kind of sleeping it off
as you sleep
These memories
leak into your
dreams you see yourself in a
place lit with
torches all around you feel something carving
near your leg like
someone or something just carving pieces out of your body as
That piece is taken away from you and fed to
a sickly person right in front of you as that happens the dream kind of melds together and
The other moment you see the same person is being
Stabbed and their blood is being drawn upon you
As the blood is getting absorbed by your body the dream then melds into a
Final like
Awakening inside of you which right now the moment that you're feeling
The emotion that you're feeling is just hatred pile on top of more and more and more just suffering
The people around you just keep dying dying over and over and the cycle of this
People just taking it away from you and just bringing the head back to you is
Never ending you feel
Time just passed through you in the
The sense of just dread
As you open your eyes is the day that you are supposed to depart for north
So
You
Did you hear any of that
I did okay, okay, I was just making sure I rode here
All right, he just like works up breaking out of the sweat
And then he's like
It's my hand
I
I thought what you before he still won't leave me alone
Um as you wake up you
Feel a knock at the door
It's just like tap not not like at not they're not banging on the door
Someone's really hesitant to maybe wake you up
Who is it?
You hear the person in front in front of the door say it's Tegore captain
I like stuff a lot of bed and go open the door
Okay, um, he's like well captain
Dravel seems to be ready. He's just pacing a lot
I don't know if he's worried or what's a deal and you should talk to him
All right
When we are ready
I'll go talk to him. Oh, I'll inform everyone
As soon as
Tegore gets out of your site he wants to work like everyone else's chambers
Malphys is already on the deck while the role-mysk is cooking in the kitchen
you
arrive at the deck and
You just see Dravel's just walking back and forth back and forth
Just walking nervously
nervous
Well
See the last times I did this it didn't go and oh
Well, I could have
You know, imagine
But no, no, I'm ready. I'm ready. This is this is the only way
I'm ready whenever you guys are
This
If you can get us close we can handle the rest
Right
About that
So do we just want to
Had to the island or do we want to go somebody close by?
Because I didn't really hear some any sort of plan
Or destination
Look they are planning to go back to spirit click right no
Is spirit clipped out in the North?
No, no, scriptures, but in the east you guys came from these
The north of
Malthus and Bob word
The name of the two islands that you know off in the North
You
Lexi in period where like the final judgment of
what you
Think or them is going to be taken place and then you got new salt where
Drowman's execution is casual
And you don't know the layout of the place you just know you just heard the names
You don't know where it is you don't know where what's it about
If we can just get close to the island
Which one I feel like
Don't say the one that
What's his name told us that they were heading to
Yes, we do in first right?
Lexi in period the judiciary island. Yeah, yeah, okay the one for
Close okay by I don't want to be you know
But I really do need to know how close
If someone saw your ability
Yes, what you wanted
Well
As
There's your answer
Okay, I'll try my best
Just in case I would advise everyone to maybe hold on to something
Everyone get below that
As you do that
As everyone turns away you see draves
puts down his
weapon
Right beside him as
He
puts both of his hands together and
As he spreads them apart you just hear this rumbling out of the seas
You and you see this giant pipe coming out right in front of the ship
It's way bigger than the ship. It keeps rising keeps rising keeps rising. You see the water
Getting split apart. You see the fishes being thrown away from
The pipe itself and as you see this pipe finally emerge out of the water you don't see an
Edge to it you don't see an end to it you start to sail the ship right inside
All right
As Draveau's finally says
Final technique a
Thousand-mile tunnel
As this huge channel appears near the end of it you just see darkness as you start to go
deeper and deeper and deeper
They're at one point there is no light in the tunnel even with your
Eyes you don't see anything
except for the splashing of water around the ship
And I'm gonna roll on the table and see where the fuck you end up
Oh, that's not good. That's not good six. Oh my god
Well, it's in there
It's not that it's the table for teleportation. It's just rough
See
Let's focus the mishaptid
Okay, that's great. I don't see the mishaptid
The team
Yeah, let's look up the teleportation
Okay
Um
As you
Hear like the
Water splashing around the ship
After one point you just hear like a complete silence and nothing's
Making a sound anymore as
Immediately you just start free falling
Everyone just start
Banks up toward the top of the below deck
Everyone can you guys make good?
I think it's just damage actually
Yeah, everyone takes 13 damage
But now you're still free falling the ship is falling
I'm gonna make a
Like damage check for the ship
And if it breaks it breaks I can't I can't do anything about that
Ship
What was the threshold
I forgot what the threshold was I guess it doesn't matter
You're gonna fall
50 feet from the air into the water
32 and it's not that bad
We've seen it this the ship takes 30 damage
You see like parts of the reinforcement that
What's his name fucking?
Bramble put
Not wearing off so
Probably the work that Bramble did kind of maybe saved you at this point, but
Everyone seems to be okay. They've just hit themselves all over the place
Especially in this time Dravo's had made his way
Down to the below deck, but as you turn around you just see Dravo's completely passed out
Get home to a bird
Tegor looks at you and goes all right captain
He's gonna take dravo's and put him in one of the beds
All right
As you
Move out
Into the above deck
The fall doesn't seem to have caused a lot of damage the animals are kind of
In a frenzy sort of but they also have seemed to calm down
By the time you guys made it a bit away from where you first fell at
As like the waves have carried you a bit further
Right in front of you you see
Two islands
Separated by this underground sorry underwater waterfall
But it's not like it's just the density of water is a bit different and between those two islands you see a giant bridge connecting these two islands
You're pretty far away from the islands
Yeah
If you want to scope it out
I
Don't think so I don't think anyone would have any knowledge of the island currently
Well, this what you see
Two uns connected by bridge
Nothing major from here
It seemed like we were supposed to be headed
No, I don't
Do they look like Navy Island?
Do you have
You have a scope. Thank you probably doing like the navigator supply
Yeah, okay, just roll for
Perception I guess from far away you can only check where basic things
Like big ass flags with Marie will see
See if you can spot them right it depends like which angle you came in from okay
You look around you do see on both of those islands you do see
Marine flags like right in front of like a bunch of buildings
Near the edge of those islands
Between like the bridge connecting from one
Doc of the island to other talk of the island you do see a bunch of warships
Navy warships lined so no one gets passed
Like in between that those bridges without getting checked
As far as you can tell you also see a bunch of
Warships lined up on the island on on your right
But you don't really see a lot of warships on the left inside you do see a lot of
maybe
merchant boats small fisher boats and so on so forth near the dogs as you zoom in through your lenses
So
So the only zone left and Navy on the right mostly
Or the way around
Yeah, yeah mostly on the right you see Navy ships and on the left you see
Just like civilian ships
Well
Why be best to talk on the right
The right seems to be heavily occupied
All right
Tell me when he gets back to
Navigate us in that direction
Kate gets back up he does see where you want to go
He's kind of hesitant in any looks at you as he gets do you think it's a good idea to
Just go in the dock. Maybe we should
Go around and find somewhere safe to dock the ship
We do have the pirate flag
And considering if we are where we are supposed to be on they be looking for us
We did just add our
Well, let's
That's a good idea
See if you can get us
somewhat
Kate is going to like turn away from the island
As he like pulls up the masts from above and kind of closes in slowly moving drifting away
On the light left inside of the island as he's like turning around
And not like entering the island from the dock itself
He takes you like the long way around the island toward the
Other side to maybe see if there's a safer place to dock
at
as
He like takes like a big loop around the island
He spots one place he points it at he points it to you mouth as he goes
Malfa, can you look in if that place seems safe to
Maybe put a ship in he points to you to like a sort of like natural cave
Built into the side of the island
Is it I mean you can do perception check if there any threats or not
If you're not sure we can go either way
Yeah, as you look
Toward that you do see like an entrance to
Cave but it does not really look like
Natural cave to you
You see like a bunch of like artificial lights
Plugged into the cave. Maybe it's a entrance meant for some other party or
meant for some other trading routes. You're not sure
Well, it was the only thing we have right now bed and leave it out in the open
All right, you like give a agreeing nod to
Kade as he like
turns the
Wheel around and starts to head into bad cave
All right, that's me like check for him
As you start to head in you do see like a bunch of like
rocks or like boulders sticking out
Toward the entrance of the cave so it's like very difficult
Navigating into
Where is he there we go
Yeah, it's been rough for everyone
Carpenters tool, okay, there's a ship right tools, but I guess I'll just do
Normal wisdom for him
See if you can navigate through
Yeah, that should be good enough
You see the ship
like bump into
Like the sides of these rocks, but you easily like kind of navigate through
You see this back channel leading into an area which leads up
Near like a place where you can
Store the ship at and
As you arrive at this junction kind of which leads
Another way leading up toward the right side
From where you entered and there's one place where you can just get off and
Take some stairs that you can spot from the deck
After you we can go deeper or you can get off here and
Keep the ship here leave
Maybe best we go on foot
Yeah, let's talk it
Okay, as you
Talk the ship
He lets the anchor down
Tigora looks at you and he goes
I think it's best kept in if I stay behind look up at the ship
You're doing it
You can improve as well
What
Take that over the tables, okay, okay, yeah
Yeah, yeah
Yeah, he seems to be in
In a bad condition and I'm not sure what happened
It I
Think I might need a bit of backup. It would be good if someone could stay behind
Maybe guard the ship with me
Hey Bob you're saying
No, Bob's like yeah, I'm saying goodbye
All right, it's you three thing where you need to hang on the ship
Yeah, as you guys
Get off and start to
Hold on hold on hey listen sons of bitches. I cooked breakfast for you
You you made me make a mess with whatever the fuck you were doing out here. You're better be eating something
You're better be eating something I gotta go clean a mess up in there. I don't know what the where the fuck are we?
Was in their cooking nobody came in and told me what the fuck's going on?
When when did y'all come into the kitchen right before everything happened
He got probably came in but you were just cooking and then pay attention
Exactly he nobody stopped me from what I was doing
Y'all needed some food. I got food now y'all gonna eat this food right now
I didn't just slave over it for like the last hour for y'all just not to eat the shit
You go kind of looked at you and goes
Maybe a good idea to
You know stock up in case we can't find anything in case you guys can find it anywhere to
Save please stay at
All right, I guess what are we doing are we
Taking a break and like getting ready
Okay, everyone takes a plate and y'all start to eat rummoo. Do you want to roll something?
Do you have anything to like
Didn't you have something to like short rest or something?
Thought you did yeah, yeah, I got the I could create those cookies after every short rest or hold on
We all take your mod does something yeah
So would you say back in cooking?
Nothing
That's pretty
At the end of the short rest any creature who eats the food regains an extra one d8 hit point
Okay, at the end of the short rest
As part of the short rest I create four plus my proficiency bonus at the end of that short rest they get one d8 of hit points
Okay, that you can use it at any point
or
Okay, okay, so everyone roll one d8 and add it to your HP
Is it is it H.H.P.O. Temperature. It's probably a step pray
Or do you just gain it back? Oh?
Okay, I see I see it's like it's like in between short rest. Okay
It's not worth it right now. Yeah, yeah
So I got seven
No, no, it's meant to be like oh you're just you just have been in a fight and then you take short rest to gain your HP and then you can get one d8 bonus if you
Cook meal
Yep, and it says with an hour work you when you finish a short rest are longer so I can cook another
Some more treats
Yeah, for the treats you can write them down like how many treats you have right now
Oh, you are not at full HP for something
Because we took the 13 from dropping oh
I mean, sorry
God, I forgot
I mean you guys can do the short rest and get the things if you want to or
You can just skip the short rest or something
I guess you are like kind of waiting and eating so I guess you just take the short rest
47 then I'll add 70 your HP Roma everyone else can also roll and add that to your HP
Is it same for everyone or do they have to roll for them health?
It says that they all have to roll like from what this says
Hmm, it says they roll a 1 to 8
All right, yeah, everyone will 1 to 8 add a 2 HP that you lost
Is it normal or 10?
Normal
Did take 13 damage right?
Ah
Oh
Put me at
42 plus
You're taking anything else other than like you and your basics of lies
This is a show
What happened
Do you want to take anyone else?
I mean you have the dog and everything
Want to take me I would be if the dog wants to come with me because he doesn't usually so
I
Mean it's up to you. It's it's a very risky situation you want to get into. I don't know if you want to take the dog or not
He makes experience all right
Level up the dog the spirit will what the huh
Yeah, he should be he should just jump on you as you're leaving
Just kind of
wants to leave the ship for a while I guess
If you're coming with me if there's ever a moment
The things get rough you gotta
Run back to the nose
No, we're the return to
All right, he kind of looks back toward the ship and just starts to walk
towards the stairs
Okay, you guys had a meal
Roma you have your supplies your snacks ready at any point to be distributed everyone got there
Potions and supplies and everything
Yeah, all right
I don't really have a lot to break
What I don't even I don't really have a lot but I got everything
Uh, you have a small med kid right
Yes
Um
If you want you can take some supplies from Bob if he has any
That's fine we good
All right, um roll for the puzzle box to
Once
No, that was not enough. I know we have ever finished this
All right
You
Um exit out of the stairs you see the lining of the stairs kind of leaning up to this like big giant door
um, and
You start to hear like some voices from the other side of the door
What are you doing
I really listen to the voices um, who is in front
Who is leading oh
My head for just
If I see Roma chart approach with us to sneak I will tell him to stop
What
I miss dad sir
If
Me and mouth is
Go to like listening in if I see Roma trying to get close to the same I'm gonna tell him to stop
All right
Uh robot he tells you to stop
That's okay. I'm a way for him to leave and then it's gonna be like Chris Farley
Trying to be a stealthy
Reckon into shit
Um
You and mouth has put your ear to the door to try to listen in as to what's happening
um
Can you guys roll for perception?
Uh great
Great
Okay um
mouth as you do here uh like faint voices
Uh, but you hear one person saying
Uh, you sure the food's ready
I'll take it up to the um young master
He might be leaving for work soon
I guess all you hear oh my god
Roma with your uh
Here's
Yeah
He's like
This is all you over here um baptist from your side you can't really hear anything you just see like a bunch of sorry here like a bunch of rumbling
Uh people like running up in downstairs
I stuff like that
I
How many people can you put out um
All right if one of you can give me there's one key point
I can tell you how many people
What the fuck in here
I would just focus on the food
I mean you're I just said like the food part you hear but you're not really close to the door so you can't really hear anything else
If you can't give me that then it's up to you
Oh that only might there's at least two
Um okay
How so you're giving me your key point one key point
No
Okay, so sub to you
It's at least two
Well, we know there's at least two people
Yeah, so what do you want to do?
Let's see if we can find a way in
I mean you're right option at the door
What do you want to do? You just want to go in the Shilas quietly open yeah quietly open the door okay do a stealth roll for me
Oh
Nice um okay at this point only baptis has like correct open
um the door slightly
um baptis you could spot uh
Someone dressed up as like in a butler
Uh butler's dress like um suit and you can see him like directing some people toward
Places and you see like a big giant table in front of him with like a bunch of
Food and like documents and everything lined up and as he's giving away like tasks to the other
Workers there
Everyone's like dressed up in suits and everything blue and white kind of suit
Oh
From that um
You can also see above
Where the butler standing you see kind of like a small flag maybe like a family crest hanging hanging from the top
And it's like um
It's a flute with golden embroidered um
Like stuff on it like gems and whatever
Do I recognize the symbol? No you have no idea
Excuse me please
Well seems like something between you that's the only
I'll just like remember myself around the realm
Uh you want to get out of the door
Yeah, okay
You sneak out um right now everyone like the butler and everything are looking away from you you're kind of behind like
staircase so the vision is like kind of obscuring but if you step out of the staircase you will be like in broad
Like lighting in front of everyone and someone can spot you from there
No from where I'm at I just I want to just listen in then to see if I hear anything then
We're different um
Okay, you want to close the door behind or you want to keep it open so my office can look as well
Oh
Well if my office chooses to bother that's your office
Okay, you don't close the doors or just don't make any additional noise. That's all I'm asking
Okay, uh you
Huddled behind the
Um staircase now that you can see like the whole room completely
Um, you see like this is like the
Kind of like the floor
Ground floor of this whatever what seems to be because the ceiling is very high
So it seems to be like someone's mansion or something and you see like the
the carpets and the
drapes and everything all of them are like blue with like silver linings
around and
All you can spot is just this emblem put everywhere around this hall
um and the the main guy the butler
Seems to be just guiding everyone toward their task
And you just hear like a bunch of people running down the staircase that you're
Close to and people running up the staircase that you're close to
And yeah, that's that's about it. I mean nothing new. It's just you see here instructions
Um, the butler is pointing out um
Soon if you wait like around five to ten minutes
You do hear someone shouting from from top as uh, they go
Jeremy
Where's my tea
Uh, the butler turns around as he goes um
Alice is bringing your tea to you sire not not your sister
um and
The voice kind of fades away as it's like uh towards the
Top of the stairs that you are like hiding behind it kind of fades away and you hear someone rushing in as they
Um, ask the butler in front of the door that where
Everyone is and he seems to just shrug it off and he goes
There are all in their rooms and the guy just sprints away
Outside the mansion
Nothing notable happens other than that
And i like hear him
Brinto why do i not hear anyone else nearby
Um, not really
Now try to like sneak up the stairs at this point
No, then um you try to sneak up the stairs can you make another stealth check for me this time
with disadvantage
Welp
Um as you try to go up at the stairs you put one foot on the um
What do you call it the the the stairs and it kind of creaks the old butler that you spotted earlier just turns around and goes
Right
Who might you be and uh why are you inside um are mentioned
Nothing the better question is who might you be
No, no, no, I'm quite certain that the better question is who are you because I don't know you
And this is not a spot for
Stributors
I'm just looking for food right having eaten it
Another one of those beggars sir cash in brought you in then
Well
Okay
He really needs to stop burying beggars inside the house
Well, you just left so
I'm going to ask nicely that you leave
Otherwise we will have an escort throw you out
What will it be?
These get food first
No, you cannot ormen like you don't deserve
Our respect
Earn for yourself
Why don't you
But he promised to be food well then ask him
You should be at work right about now
You should be able to find him I suppose that's where you met
The best dangerous up there
What do you mean this is the safest island in the north
How is it dangerous
The way you speaking up me now is the way they speak of me out there
Yeah, well if you were worth assault then they wouldn't now get out
And put but I am worth the salt I can prove it
I could not care less now don't get in my way
All right, we'll have to call the guards. I am asking nicely for the last time leave
Okay
He points you towards like the exit of the mansion as two of the other
servants like kind of open up the door
For you to leave as they give you like this side eye of this dust
How many people can I see at this point?
You can spot at least six to seven people on the above floor
And on the ground floor you see three the one guy and two butlers that are opening the door for you and you spot other three on top of this
They're all looking at me right now. They're all looking at you. Yeah
And nobody sees mouth is just had hanging from a fucking open door like
Okay, the door is like kind of in in the way of the staircase so you have to get out
Like get out of the shadow of the staircase to everyone to see you
It's kind of maybe like a hidden entrance to the house
I'll do one of those slow walks
That people do when they want someone to stop them as I go out the door
Okay, you get do that no one's gonna stop you
Looking back every so often
I don't have time for your nonsense to get out
No one's gonna pity you
What you regret this yeah, yeah sure I am
Can I do it inside one him really quickly? Sure
I'm looking for you now
You
What's his HP?
Uh, his HP should be about 20
Oh
Are we close enough to the kitchen where I would be able to smell the ingredients?
Uh, you would be able to smell the food that's on the table but not not to the kitchen
Okay, perfect so
Gormon I can smell if there there's anything harmful
In that food like it there's secretly poisoning the food
Mm-hmm. So you want to check that?
Yeah
Now that that this food just looks to you like this tasteless mush like smells to you
Like this tasteless mush and that's a it seems like some mobile crap
Some alike
As I'm walking out I just say that's your map and then just run off
Okay
All right, well, Melphus and Roma, are you doing it?
That's a good question
Hmm, as you run out of the mansion you see like this giant like
Pathway leading to where like the outside
With these large gates and the whole place is like surrounded by these big walls
um
You can start to head out you see a bunch of guards walking in and out
As they look at you and he goes
another one of those
Stratular to the young lord bought in I suppose
How can you do even I feel sorry for this one
The funny thing is you dress normally
All right, Melphus, what are you doing? You're still heading outside?
I'll circle back once I get to a good distance
Good distance from where because the this pathways just leading towards like the main gate and once you're outside the gate you can't really head back in
Am I being washed this all time? Yeah, yeah, the guards are like all the well though
Way around the place. It's heavily guarded. Whatever this place is
Well
While I'm walking out then I'll just go out the areas of like
Get a feel of how many people and like see if I can figure out what this place is
Um, you get outside and you just see like a bunch of like
Sectored out like mansions all around this place like the whole pathways just filled with these
Um, you can start moving away and soon enough you will find like a big
um, open area that leads up to this like giant cathedral type building
Um, and you just see a bunch of people like going in and out of that place
In the center you just see a big fountain
Uh, water fountain with like a bunch of like fairies and angels like
um
statues in between
Um
Our go to the cathedral
Maybe I can get some information from there
Okay, um, um, why is this is happening as you're walking into the to do what are you doing? Mouses and Roma
Following
He's in charge
Uh, yeah, but how are you following?
You go to the mentioned
You didn't get any like comments from him, so
So what I figured
I don't know this is exactly what I'm I was trying to get out of you guys, but you didn't say anything so
You know what just for the sake of
brevity let's just say he has one and you have one
Oh
Oh, it gets all calling
Hi
You saw something on the other side
Hey, kick me out
Well
If you guys can get in
Do stuff but
I'm following a new week
There's like a theater all over here
Hey, maybe I can get you a wait there
But this place is heavily guarded
I don't know exactly this place is but
Whoever's running it must be quite the big shot
You'll see if there's still no one somewhere else
Um
Hey, stay up there
You do
Uh, yeah, all right, Roma let's look around
What are we doing?
Finding another way out
So when I head down the stairs again
Yeah
You can head down the stairs but the only place it leads up to is the ship
And
Where we came into the cave
Can we maybe climb up there somewhere through the shores
Yeah, yeah
You can't climb up because it's a cave dug into the thing but you can fly up
Well, yeah, but I'd like the address of the cave maybe you just
Get up there
So I'm going to the cave
Yeah, yeah, you can head up there for how how is Roma giving to head up there
Yeah, that's a problem. That's why it's like maybe I could climb
No, there's no way you can like
Get something to like get a leverage on additional stairs or anything or ladder
So question for you
That door
The door both
And that teeth walk through is that into the kitchen?
No, no, no, it's again, it's against
Against like a stairway it's not into the kitchen the main hall kind of has like a big giant table
where like the
Other coax and chefs put the food in front of the butler and the main butler to check and other work items to put on the table
And then he
Gives a way past for the day stuff like that then that the kitchen is pretty far away from wherever you were
Okay, so
He just walked
Like that he's just walked through the building and they'll just walked out like yeah, okay
They just thought it was someone someone else brought in like pick pick it pity on or something
Promise something might be called Christmas fish is every else so yeah, yeah again. It's up to you
Whatever you want to do
And is that butler still right there
Yeah, yeah, he's still giving away orders and he's taking like dendin moushi calls over the table
So mouth is just flying up and around I'm gonna walk in and be like
What's my order boss I'm supposed to be cooking something
La di da la di da like okay, okay. What do you need what do you need cooked
Like I was told to come here you had down or
Well, right get my dendin moushi to Roma so if I find the piece we can still come
Okay, you hand over you then moushi to Roma you have found a play a way out of the place but
Roma I guess has to just go through this before I leave I'll just just state the Roma Roma just doing doing things to visit
Uh, it's a polarer try to try to not kill yourself. Okay
Uh, I'm asking
Too much yeah too much
It's a bare minimum man
Um, uh, all right Roma
You head up to the main bapler guy and he looks around and goes and who the hell are you supposed to be
I'm your guys this new cook. I was just told to come and get some orders from you like
I'm supposed to dice up something like I don't know. I was just told to come and talk to you
Uh, I can rule the subject
Well, hey be deceptive
Deceptive
Also the only make probably at this whole other nation. Yeah, I mean again, it's like they can hire people outside of the place but
Yeah, but Roma just kind of starts out. Yeah
But anyone would believe that he's a cook for sure
Uh, he looks at you. We got up and down and he goes
Right
Okay, um, we've had some problems with our chef already
um
Right um, you can head that way he points you toward like the right quarter or leading out of the room
He goes at that way and that's the kitchen
Yes, sir what what what am I supposed to prepare they told they told me you were gonna tell me what
Like who said these
useless
They put everything on me like I'm supposed to do their job
You were the cook so cook whatever you feel is right
Get whatever supplies you have in order and make it work
And do not ask questions. Okay, so execute orders. What's your job? Ow
I
Like
You just hired me. I just need to know what they like
Like do they like a romic stuff that smells good stuff that tastes good
You just gotta point me in the right direction. Okay, he points to you to like this rotisserie chicken that he has on the
table and he goes
It should look just like this but taste not like crap you understand that
Yes, sir, so you want you want nice little lord whale heart is not a patient man
Get to work
Say less. I'll be I'll be bad. Okay. I
Someone take this guy away from me
Uh, I just told you I'm leaving five people okay
You had it into like the kitchen
What are you doing?
There seems to be uh someone working in the kitchen at this point with a bunch of other people
I'm gonna walk in and just be like you guys are doing this shit all wrong
My fucking skillet on the fucking table and be like listen here. I heard the shit tastes like shit
Uh, we are we are starting all over
You see this
Like man with like a giant mustache like the mustache is like
So big that it leads up to his like stomach and he looks up at you and goes
Hey
I'm the new cook that they hired because your shit tastes like you cook
I'm the cook of this place
Not anymore. I heard your shit tastes like ass. They said they hired somebody new because you're bad
So you big fella get to wash in dishes
And I'm gonna point to like his sous chef next to him and be like you start chopping
Uh
Ingredients I need time. I need a regga know I need paprika. I need all that get it going
So yeah, sir and the guy like kind of marches in takes a bunch of like carrots and starts to like chop them and
The other people around the place also kind of like stiffen up and just walk uh right up to you and stand in a straight line and they kind of like
Put out their arms and they kind of salute you and he goes sir on or sir
All right, I'm just gonna go start
Start down the line you you start preparing a nice little soup. It's gotta be flavorful, but simple you
Start preparing dessert. I'm thinking I
We're gonna do chocolate silk pie. You know how to make that doesn't matter figure it out get going and I'm just gonna start
All of them like disperse and go into like each area
And then I'm gonna slowly walk up
To everybody the dude making the pie. I'm just gonna dip a finger in and then taste it and be like it's all wrong
Start over
More flavor make it with love son of bitch and I'm gonna go to the big man who's probably still just standing there like what the fuck's going on
I'd be like I told you motherfucker get to wash in them dishes
Sir yes, sir. He kind of confusing if you walk stores like this thing and starts to watch this is whether which are already washed
Is like it just puts them back in
Minute what the fuck is happening no you all answered to me. I'm your captain this guy needs to get out
All of them kind of hesitate
And then I'm gonna be what was the what was the lord's name again?
whale heart
That are you gonna be the one who tells long why you're gonna tell his cook to get out because your shit tastes like garbage
Everyone just gets back to their work and this guy is just not listening you walks up to you. He goes
Look big man. I'm not here to make trouble. All right
I earned this position. I work tirelessly though for these fools for years
And now I'm promoted at the head chef. I'm not gonna let you take that away from me
I never heard about this new chef hiring anyway
Don't realize they're getting replaced until it's too late
Now like I said get to wash in dishes and I'm gonna take my frying pan
And just smack it on the table
Or we're gonna have some issues
Oh, we have some issues all right. He takes like this butcher's knife and just smack it on the table as well
As he just stirs right into you
All right
Is not a cookoff is definitely not a cookoff
You want to settle this?
Cookoff
Let's go
There are no time for a cookoff he takes his leg
Butcher's knife and just slams right into you
Oh, he like back in or front in
front in later blade blade. He's not
He's not fucking round
Okay, all right, let me cut me
Let me see if it is
Oh
It is 23
Okay
Or it slices you up
Just like slightly from your side and it's up to you. What do you want to do?
Oh, I'm taking my pan and going across his head all right, let's go ahead and we doing it
We doing it twice if the first one doesn't knock him out there
All right, let me
Right
Roma let's do this
26 hits
Is it all the damage?
I think it's 18 critical, right?
Yeah, 18 19 20 years it's 18 80 80 80
19 20 I think pretty sure we
10 it doesn't matter he's gonna knock out
Yeah, you know I came out and I'm a knock I'm a knock him out and turn to everybody be like does anybody else have issues
No, no center
Everyone gets back to work
And the guy just like immediately just slams on the table and goes down on the floor
Hey
Now I'm gonna go through and I'm gonna make sure everybody's flavorful
Has flavor and is impactful
Okay, let me roll
40 10
40 20 right
Except for the first and last guy everyone seems to be cooking fine
Hey the first and last guy
I'm a point in about be like you to suck start over make it fast
Yes, sir
And they start over again in like 10 20 minutes
Uh
Yeah, it does seem serviceable
Okay serviceable not good enough
All right
And this goes on for a while I'm gonna shift to the other people for now and we'll come back
Oh the first one succeeds the second one just sucks
It's the third dude
Yeah
All right, I'm gonna move back to
Melvus Melvus you fly up uh around as you kind of fly up a bit above
The the tree level you do spot like a bunch of mansions lying around in this uh like
Shape uh like this complete like sector of this place seems to be like these mansions like big big mansions
And you do spot the cathedral right in the center
uh
And as it divides to like other sectors of the place
What do you know so walk that
But you uh fly down into like this
Kind of like a hidden area behind an alleyway near the cathedral and you start walking up toward it you spot
Baptiste kind of like rarely going inside the cathedral and um yeah
Baptiste you
Immediately see a bunch of Marines walking around in the cathedral
And you kind of see like a few people working on maybe a platform
Uh in the middle of the cathedral
You
Is
The
Uh, it's basically like
pretty like
Pretty much normal. It's not normal in the sense like there's no people like praying or anything
It's just
Constructed like a cathedral and not much else
Wait a minute
Marines everywhere
The cathedral built a platform
Okay
Uh, Melvus you quickly follow uh oh god
Jesus Christ you have no clue you have no clue what's happening
Melvus you quickly head inside and see Baptiste uh looking around kind of scratching his head like what the fuck is happening
What you could talk what would you say
I might have a clue what's going on but might finish
You you understand immediately what the hell is happening
Uh
What
Uh, you have you do have um
What do you call for can you inside your clothes trying to like peek outside
From your cloak
Um
I'll take a mountain hold him
In the open
It's the the dog
Yeah, yeah, yeah, sure sure. Yeah, you hold them outside
All right, Melvus you and Baptiste are
The same place now
I can't put my finger on what this place could be used for
Oh
congregation but
If earlier god would tell us what it is
What do you mean I thought you knew
Uh, okay, essentially to you Melvus it looks like it's sort of an execution platform
Yeah, see I was going there but I was like is it?
Yeah
And you look around the place and you see a bunch of uh
Markings around the place like boards leading to like different paths of the island and so on so forth one of the boards points
toward like the
East east words and it says um
What the fuck was the name of that?
Lexi in period and one of the boards that Lee that points southwards um says like news hole docs
They think they want to execute her
Turns out we made it to the island wanted to
Yeah
Let's see if we can
Let's try to look around see if they can get a layout the area
It is like a public execution are like posters like execution of
No, they don't advertise the execution. They already said whose execution is planned on the fucking paper
Right
In the papers it was mentioned that the execution of draves was
scheduled to be on news hold
Couple weeks from now so it's not now because it's still in construction the it's planned
Wait drapes is also execution here and not just them
Now zim is going to be taken to the judicial uh system and she's going to be charged
That there's gonna be a whole process then her
The like charges supposed to be is she going to be imprisoned she going to be executed the that's not decided yet
We're on the wrong island
So this is news hold then this is news hold and um
Lexi imperia is uh the other island through the bridge that you saw that was heavily guarded
Was that where all the ships are just the same island base please
Yeah, there's like twin islands just separated from the from this why this like
underground underground
All right, I thought you were to like islands like a fucking distance away
No, no, no, it's not that far. Why would there be a fucking bridge with these islands?
I didn't know it was the other
I get it I get it now I get it
So it's basically Lexi imperia is placed there because most of the cases that come into the
uh
Like imperial uh judiciary system they just lead to news hold and news hold this name that because people get hanged here
I get it yeah
Everyone everything makes sense now with your 25 wisdom chair
It's coming together
The tall going together guys
So fucking mouth is going to mind palace
Didn't figure all the shit out
Wait a minute
All right, yeah, Battees got distracted by
Moon it's just like yeah
All right, uh while you guys have this realization that you're on the other island
Uh
Roma what is up
It seems to be like a couple of to attend to 20 minutes have passed and everyone has
Seems to figure out what they're cooking and everything looks good
Up to your hands and so as everybody's cooking like I'm gonna dip into like a
Sideroom and I'm gonna give mouth as a call
And I'm gonna be like
Whoever has
I'm just gonna give whoever is holding the thing to come be like
I'm waiting
Rolling
Well nobody nobody gonna
Who's answering?
I don't have a snail on me, so yeah, I was distracted
From one
Battees to have an ink on me call
Probably Roma
I'll answer it
You just hear a blue bark but act at you
Yeah
You still like it
Oh, I'm so I'm running the kitchen right now
Got these motherfuckers working on
Roma
Battees, what do you mean?
I'm running the kitchen, what's it we
Got these motherfuckers working on them we make it a hot ass meal
This is gonna be so good. What do you guys need me to do
Like is this still bad or good do you need me to poison them?
Well, we're on the wrong island
So we just leave it like well you you remember that bridge
Need to cross that well
Here's the thing
They're expecting we got the report and
They're expecting us to attack
And get them first
I mean
We saw the report that boy. I had a whole fleet just for the pants board expecting an attack
And she is scheduled to be tried first
If we were to get a trobin now we might face less resistance than
closer to his execution
Okay, question
Um just little insight
Whoever was in charge of this kitchen crew
Said he was the captain of something. I have no idea second thing
again
What do you all need me to do I can
Do you just need me to post up for keep pretending like I ain't got much time because I gotta get back and make sure these people ain't
Fucking up this food my name's on the line
Practice find out about the report. Have any of any information?
What what
So I'd find out anything maybe
Okay, give me a call if you guys need me again
Okay
You know what
What what did you say about these
Good work Roma
Okay, I like I said just let me know because I gotta I gotta crew full of people out there that are
We are preparing a feast of some sort for
Some Lord whale
Name
Lord whale heart
I think it's some dude named Lord whale heart you ever heard of that
The name familiar you said no no no
Oh
What what
This
Daryter and I'm on I'm on hang up the dinner. We'll she put it out there and I'm on walk out there
And the scrawny is looking dude the scrawny is looking to probably the one who used to be used to be the
Um the dude who cleans all the dishes. Yeah, yeah, the guy you put on dessert
Like I put on dessert. Yeah, I'm gonna look at him and I'm gonna be like
I'm gonna walk up to him and can speak the newest pimple like
You know tasting everybody's food along the way and I'm gonna be like all right dude
You fucking up to this dessert
What is going on? Are you intimidated by this whale heart like what is going on big fella
No
You need to be you need to be but I need to know like what has you scared about this whale heart so damn bad
Sir what's he doing Lord whale heart is a judge for Lexon period sir. He's he's about to be scheduled for his hearing tomorrow sir
He needs his food sir
Yes, sir judge
Sir all of the people around this area are the judge that work for Lexon period all of their houses are guarded by Marines and
they
reside over the
Lex Imperial Judicial System
sir
Perfect I need you I'm gonna give you a special mission
So yes sir I'm gonna need you I'm gonna need you to go contact the head butler and tell him that we need
To throw a big feast for all of the judges around okay. I'll take over your dessert while you do this
But let let him know we need to invite all of the families all of the judges here and we need
Big fellow a big
Part tonight we have a big feast so I'm and I'm gonna turn around to every all the other cook
So I'm gonna be like we are preparing a feast tonight for everyone. I need a
Right as you say it
You
A hand right behind you and you see this butler kind of like pissed off the head butler that you saw earlier
What exactly is happening here?
We're preparing the food like you told me to feast it all your your head chef. There is no feast
Do you understand me do your job
And this stuff is to be figured out by people who are much
More powerful than you you are a mere cook
Do your job
Bring the food up to the Lord
I tell you to do whatever you
Are paid to do if you do not comply you can leave we can found find another chef or whatever you call yourself
I'm gonna take I'm gonna take a little spoonful of dessert and I'm gonna shove it in his mouth
And pray that it is the best food he is okay. Can he roll work?
All right, let me cook you ten soul if you fuck it up now it would be so funny. Yeah
Why is it okay? It's not popping up there. Oh, it is my thing was just covering it. I'm sorry
Come on. Oh
Okay, that's right. Yeah, he takes like a bite. He kind of
Tastes it. He thinks about he closes his eyes and he looks at you and goes
Well, I guess you are worth your salt
None the matter you take the food up to the Lord. He is getting late for his caravan
I will think about this feast idea of yours. Maybe this will help
What
The reason I'm saying a feast
Judge whale heart has the best chef on the island the best one and I want to show my
skills
To all of them and let him glow that he has the best chef around okay
That is what I'm trying to say take the food up to the Lord and maybe put that idea in front of him and if he likes your food then
He might be willing
To let that happen neither
In either case
I don't think the feast is
Going to happen anytime soon the judge is pretty busy with his daily task
Okay, so I'm gonna start I'm gonna tell the scrawny little fuck to grab a tray
And that I'm gonna be like
I'm gonna start assembling his food
And I guess I'll take it up there with the scrawny little doom
All right
You take like 10 to 20 minutes to start like garnishing the food and maybe like
Setting it up nicely for like a little nobleman to eat or whatever right
You said the plate up and you take the scrawny dude with the dessert in his hand and you take the rest of the food with your on a plate
You knock in front of the door and you just hear yes come in
I'm walking and I'm gonna I'm gonna lay the food down and I'm be like
What would he be mister or would he be lord lord like
I'm gonna be like lord whale heart. This is
I am chef or boroughs here
I'm head chef or boroughs. You're newly hired. This is my
My palette of food that we have prepared for you today with me and my humble brew downstairs
And here's a lovely French silk pie for dessert prepared by this j
Gentlemen here and I'm gonna lay it out and I have one humble request of you lord whale heart
The silence let me taste your food first and we will see to your request after
Roll the coke suitenses once more for the dessert. It should be fine, but just for the main
dish as you look or to him you see in front of you a guy with like
You know the head pieces that the fucking
Judges used to wear back in the day that head piece and a big mustache like white mustache leading up to his here
ear no beard and with just like blue eyes and this like blue garb with silver lining
Like a judges garb essentially as he takes his
Like place on the dining table like large dining table into his his like large
Like office room
He sits and he starts to like take the fork and knife and starts to cut
The pieces of what what do you have prepared and he just starts to take a bite as he takes the first bite he goes
Oh quite exquisite. This is the first time I'm tasting something like this
Or a Boris you say that is quite a
um
Extraordinary name I have never heard of such a name um where are you from young man
From the mountain of zoo I was trained in the arts of culinary skills by the mugs there
I see I see I've heard a lot about this a zole place
I'm not always good, but you seem to be quite capable
Now
You there young one put the dish right in front of me. What is it?
Yeah, the this grony dude kind of like shakes and puts the plate in front of him as he goes
You just keep saying that
He prepared you a lovely chocolate friend so pie with a nice fluffy moose center
And garnished with whipped cream
As you say that he puts like a spoon inside and he takes a small bite and he goes wow
Quite exquisite is this your job young fellow you look said the
But um like scrande do it kind of nods and goes
And quite well done. I suppose all you lacked was a good leadership
Um or a boroughs
Uh, I am yes you mentioned something about
Something yeah go ahead while I take a bite of this exquisite dish you made
Uh, he takes another bite and so on as he's listening to you
So I'm thinking you have an upcoming execution
Or something going on because I saw the festivities getting ready
So I'm thinking for everybody around
And for you because like you're a lord you have the finest chef
So I'm thinking we prepare a feast for all of the families. So that way you could show off to everybody
How great your chef is compared to theirs
Okay, and I'll prepare a giant feast of
Different cuisines
And you could show off to him and be like this is what I get to eat on the daily
And you get to rub it into all the other families to let them know how exquisite your food is and how rare
Like they get to have it and also celebrate whatever your guys is upcoming festivities is
You think a killing of a man is a festivity
Young man. I have no idea what's going on
I have no idea it could be depending on the right man
If he is a known criminal and you guys caught this guy and if he has a
A very
Bountiful reputations. So shall I say a very bountiful reputation
Um, it could be something where you guys might want to celebrate because you guys got the criminal you know what I'm saying
I have no idea what the man did. I have no idea who you guys are putting now
I just arrived here because somebody hired me saying your shift was it
inadequate
So they brought me in knowing that I am right now
Renon you say
I see yes
All right
well
Jefferson is
quite
capable hand learn I
suppose he chose
wisely
Regarding the execution the execution of the fellow at news hole has no
relation to the judiciary customs as the Marines
Enforced their laws above ours and I've decided to go further with the execution of the man called Revos Caligos without
due process
I hold it in contempt of law and justice
As justice was not served in that case although I am looking forward to my next case
Which is going to be this young woman in called
What was her name I blank on it
I will go through her case tomorrow and as you can see I have my work cut out for me
Or this young lady's sake I would prefer to not have these festivities as of now let's
get this dark moon done
And maybe we can think of holding
Bank quite as you say
So you want to
So you're saying no
No no feast until after the executions are done yes yes
Quite so okay
And secondly, so are you the judge of her case and Dravos's case or you just the judge of her case
You're not listening young man. I said there was no due process for this dravos fellow do press
Hey exactly
Yes, okay, okay, that's on
Well, you said you were there's no due process for dravos, but then you said you were the judge
But I don't are you the only judge for her case
Yes, yes as of now I am the only judge for okay that case itself
Okay, so then I will start preparing your dinner
We'll start to go ahead young man
How can take you leave how do you feel about slow roasted pork
That sounds quite exquisite
Okay, that's all I need to know now if you don't mind you could you
Take the food to my son as well
He should be somewhere and
He should be at the courts
Yes, sir in Lex Impugia
That's really prepare a caravan for your delivery
I see that
You are quite capable and I would like my son to taste the food that you have made as well
Yes, sir
Sorry
I'm gonna leave now start preparing like preparing food to take to its own
All right, peace we gonna walk out we're gonna start preparing food
While I have the the young man there that like that scrawny dude
I'm gonna tell him to start preparing food
I'm going to tell all the other cooks in there take a 30 minute break go lay down when we come back
We gonna get after it and I am gonna dip into that same
Yes sir close the door behind me yeah
I'm gonna dip dip into the closet and I'm gonna give
uh
Baptiste the call and let him know everything that dude just told me
Baptiste as you wait around uh
Let's see what you guys have been up to in the meantime and then we'll take the call
All right you cut off your call with Roma
What are you guys up to
Once I realized it's the execution hall
Mm-hmm, and I would have been said everything about trying to get drove in first and they probably expect us to do that first
I would have started looking around for like any
Clues as to where they might be holding someone or just try to sneak behind the garden dude
The stealthy whisper of the god
Okay
All right, what are you doing melphous
Yeah, also probably scouting the plate out of it like
Maybe we say like hey, let's look around the island bit and be back here
Okay
You walk around melphous and then
Nothing much really stands out to you except for like a couple of shops
Close by to the cathedral
Outside the cathedral within the cathedral like near where the stealth stage or the platform is being built
You just see a bunch of marine presence
Uh, and that's about it
Um you walk around and you spot a couple of posters
wanted posters
And you do see uh your new posters on these pamphlet
essentially like a board
Okay, let me pull up your buttons
Like I'm walking around and
I see the poster and I just walk past on like wait a minute
Wait a minute, that's me what the fuck
Uh, of course you like right now
the biggest like
The centerpiece that you see is off obsidian for 600 million bellies
But behind that under like the buried posters you do see the new boundaries for everyone
You see blackboard black dawn baptized 130 million bellies
You see
Hexmarkina bob with 25,000 bellies
um
You see iinskillett rama with
65 million bellies
You see waiting fest malphys with 75 million bellies
And and all the other six fold bounties are the same
But you see a new bounty uh
for uh red in his human form which is now 25 million bellies
You don't recognize red
But you
But you would have heard about it from baptism drama
Like someone with the name of
um
The crimson cacophony red
Can i take the poster with me?
Uh, I mean you can yeah you can
Just roll for slide of hand
It depends if you just rip him off or you're just like sneak and taking a bite
I mean not like well everyone is watching me right
Yeah, I mean they will definitely spot you
Okay, you just go closer to the like wanted board as you rip apart like uh the poster for everyone else or just that one
Well, I mean everyone can know about these
Yeah
All right and the least picture of our faces on here the bell right
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you take off everyone everyone's bounty and you also take the poster for
Obsidian as well because it's like right in front of everyone
So you just take his poster down as well in the process
Uh, yep. All right, you take it away
Yes
Okay, Baptiste as you're like moving around
Where do you want to sneak in?
What do you want to do Baptiste? Sorry
You're still inside the cathedral right?
Do I see a guard that's like by himself
Uh, can you roll for?
Can you just make me a 1D 20?
Oh
No
All the guards are like pretty much grouped up together like in pairs of do and walking around the Marines might I add it
They're not just guards in Marines
And from where I can see there's only the platforms
There's just a platform the the platform is being built like to
uh, like pretty high up
So like everyone can look at what's happening and the area around it has nothing. It's just empty cathedral nothing
Else just people walking around
And like looking at what's being done like you know, just standing around looking at the construction being done inside the cathedral
The cathedral like it's completely like fully made
I will throw on my mask and then walk up to the the Marines
Okay, uh you walk up to the Marine and they put a hand in front and he goes that's
Right, stay back
And this should be about it the viewers need to stay behind this line
neon lookers
I know me or you are
I've been sent to
I've been
It's investigate the more I heard
The man that for execution has been putting up a bit of a struggle
And well, that's why specialty he he he dealing with people struggle
Uh, okay, can you roll for deception with this advantage?
Oh, yeah
To that's what it's called
No, uh at this point he kind of
Orchard's you and goes that's funny, buddy, because the prisoners still en route
And there's been no trouble that we've heard of
Now walk away and let your dreams be dreams fellow
Uh like point my hand towards the space
Mm-hmm
You win your petty little dreams
You know nothing of the people about you
We'll see if you make it back home tonight
Good luck with you
We'll see if you even have a job
You see the other guard kind of walking up there me
Bro, that good dude's creepy stay away from him. Just come back here
What the fuck is he saying that doesn't seem right? I don't believe in curses, but that's a curse, man
You know
Hmm
They're still at their position to the religious not messing with you
I'll just start laughing the night we hear
All right
Okay, uh right about this time you get the denim mushy call from broma
And mouth as you run up to baptize and show them the posters
You
Don't you do that once doing some of the guards?
Well, no, no, no, no, you're far away
Probably
Born and then I'll walk away from the guards
Okay, you walk away you see Malfa's approach you you show the poster and at the same time the denim mushy starts running
blah
Blah
Lunar folding corporate it. Who's calling
Hey boss
All right, you relay all that information to baptize
Everything yeah, hey baptize. Uh, so I just talked to this lord
Why do we learn whatever the hell is in the way art of what we're all
So uh, hey
They're drabos is supposed to get executed tonight
Not tonight not tomorrow
I thought I was supposed to be because no, it was supposed to be the court tomorrow was the
Hearing for them supposedly and drabos was scheduled to be
executed sometime during this week
Our next week, okay, sometimes sometimes
Sometime in the next couple weeks drabos is supposed to be
Uh executed secondly
Tomorrow there is a court hearing for zip. I don't know if that's
Important or not, but the head judge is this lord whale heart
Thirdly, I'm trying to get a feast where I could get all the judges in one area and you know
Do my thing with them. You know what I'm saying
But boss what do you do?
Hello
What do you need me to do boss
Find
He said that the judge
For his own trial is the one that you call me
That is correct
Find a way to tag along with him to the trial
Uh
Um
It's a public trial we can all attend it
No
Not publicly as part of
You think he's gonna take his chef with him
It's your job convincing to do so
Okay, I mean I could say he might need some snacks
Oh
Only could just simply poison them later
But also I'm supposed to go and deliver food to his son
We're preparing the food right now
And how did you get broken for that?
Lord whale heart told me to go and do that
We'll send you like to the board so much
The whiskey test
But what I'm asking now is uh this would be a good we're supposed to be meeting them
At some lawyerly building you know
I could slip a note in his food saying his dad needs them to meet him some place
And you know
You guys can
Do your thing with him
He was both the child ran with someone
That's on you that whatever you guys do
I'm not part of this
But I can write this note real quick and you know
Well, we deliver the food to slide it in there you know, I'm saying this
You do that yes
Okay, where do you want me to tell him to meet you
And of the docs and of the docs
Uh
Okay, and of the docs 930
All right, so I'm a I'm gonna write up that note and then have it like tucked in my hand
So when I grabbed the food I can just slide it in the packaging of the food
And I'm like all right boss
I'm gonna do this and I'm uh and then I gotta get to helping this dude
If you want me to like poison this food that like knocks him out or makes it felt ill
Like so midway through the trial he gets the shits
If that is what you think is best luck
What I just need to know because like this is something I'm preparing to do is didn't
Okay
Uh as you're talking about these just hangs it up and made away
Uh our baptism relay all that information to mouthless
Uh, what is everyone doing
What's plan
Well, we're preparing a
Mm-hmm
Go ahead and baptize at these
No, we're deciding that's the wait for you to
Uh heading back to where we're exactly
Well, I told her I'm gonna leave the note for him to lead into the ship. So I'll be just heading back to the ship
Uh your ship
Yes, your ship which is
Within the mansion
Yep
How do you how do you plan to go inside the mansion again
What do you say that man's name was Sir Crescent
Cash in
Cash
Let's actually find this Sir Crescent
Malthus
I can't go talk to those guards again because of
Issues but
Seems you can go find out something about a certain hatch
All right, I mean you can meet up with Roma
Because he's all over also leaving to like get the food to the
Sun and you want to head back to
Play
All right, I'll just wish Roma Roma you have prepared like the food that you want to get you want to deliver to
The Sun right
So uh a cart is getting ready for you to take the food
Uh right in front of the gate you see the cart and you see a bunch of guards right in front of the cart as they open the door and let you in
Uh as you're going toward uh like through the cathedral like around it uh you see Malthus walking toward the
Uh mansion
I'm not pretend like I don't see him no good
Uh Malthus you do see Roma very obviously looking at you
And kind of gives you a slight nod
Uh all right, uh Malthus you're walking
Oh hey good I'm I'm gonna see him and I'm gonna pretend to look away like I'm gonna do the oh there he is
Uh Malthus you're walking toward the gates of the mansion and you see the couple of guards standing behind the gate
What do you want to do
Yes
What do I need to figure out again
Uh about Sir Cation
Uh uh
May I ask a question of youth
Yeah you lost
Uh well yes I told me to deliver a letter to Sir Cation
and I need to have forgotten the direction
Uh you the young lord has gotten himself into more trouble
See look
We don't allow people such as yourself inside the mansion you can find Sir Cation
at his office and Lex Imperia
Now off with you
What what do you mean he's gotten in troubles
Well what are you here for some more money what do you want to beg for
Well my brother has taken me and he told me to deliver this
Uh what what are you handing over
Well no I do
My first thing was I needed to deliver a letter but uh
Who's like what do you want he's like what do you want
No what what letter the letter is going to be handed over by the one right
Well no but like trying to figure out anything
Oh okay okay uh
I don't have a letter
So okay okay okay
Whatever you need to hand him over just go to his offices
Sure he'll be happy to take you in like the rest of them
Which you'll have a map of the place perhaps
You should see Sir Cation, Wellhart
Pretty much everywhere written around where his offices are if you go to Lex Imperia the high court
You should see where his office is not hard to point
All right thank you for your time
All right
You and the guard like turns away and takes his position again
I
I'll walk back again and do the other you by your words yeah all right um
Baptiste what are you doing in the meantime
Just didn't around waiting right uh you see Malfa's approach you
And he tells you all he heard from the guards
Also Roma that didn't do a guard probably to deliver his footage
Is this like passion and
That's on the same person
Well no was this a sunrise Sir Cation Wellhart
And the other the the the Lord I Roma work for now
You think we should go find this or a cast
Uh okay Roma you yeah you can just give Roma a call you still in the
Carriage
No, no the two guards are accompanying and like the people driving
Here as well
Yeah, I mean in the carriage they might hear
Who knows
Like I'm saying like do you just follow it? I mean you can just follow it yeah
Um
Okay, Roma no I'm just going along in the carriages with with the scrawny
Yeah, yeah with the scrawny guy in the carriage and the two guards
The carriage kind of stops Roma you look outside and you see a bunch of marines
uh
Outside
And they are looking for permission to enter inside and it's one of the guards just
Uh like kind of yells at one of the marines as he says do you know who's carriage this is
This is Sir
Railhart Lord whale hearts carriage
We have special permission to enter the premises at any point
Just because you have been given priority to look over the security of the palace
Does it mean you get to this merge the name of the Lord
Justice do you understand the marine kind of
pretend the knots and
Points to the other marine to open the like um gates in front of him as the gates spread apart the cards starts running in
um and
The kind of come to a stop right in front of the doors of this like huge gigantic
uh
Like building and it's divided into like several several orders and
You hear knock at the door and the guard essentially says though you will arrive
You can go on foot from here. We'll be waiting at
Here to get you back to the mansion
Uh the scrawny dude exits takes like the
Like backpack with the food and everything
On his back and he starts to follow you
Uh before he does that
The backpack with the food, because I'm assuming like we tied the food up in like a
Like a knot and something thing. I'm gonna like straight
So I'm gonna I'm gonna grab the dudes by the backpack and I'm be like all right scrawny dude
Like we are we are approaching
The Lord's son. I need you on your back. That's behavior and I'm gonna kind of like give him a tap talk
But secretly I am slipping that note into like
One of the folds of the food. It's like
When we lay the food out nobody's gonna see the lettering until like the son takes a cover off the food. You know what I'm saying
Uh as you say that to him he goes
It should be fine sir. So so cation is a kind gentleman
We don't need to worry that much as he starts walking
uh
Keeps walking and you see like these large halls and then like uh these big
offices like covered in marble and everything you see people running around from like place to place
yelling and shouting and like arguing with each other as
You see like lines of a lot of like people you see all sorts of people here like
Marines you see
Pirates even like people like tied up into
handcuffs see prism stones every sort of person
um is around here and
Everyone's really like walking to one room other everyone's walking in the main corridor and
You see like this big giant board of essentially like every lawyer's name that works at this place and like names of
Where like a certain hearing is supposed to happen in which room and so on so forth
um
He the young kid he uh
Looks around and goes i'm i'm very familiar very
Sir cation's offices are you can just follow me you don't need to look around here
Uh, just trying to get my bearings my surroundings so that way if I ever come here by myself. I know where i'm going
Yes, yes, of course
You see cation well veil heart. You don't really see or spot it anywhere near like the
Top of the board you see one small corner just like has like written in like marker or something cation will heart
Uh, and it points towards like the west wing of the building
uh, you start walking toward the west wing
As you start walking the crowd kind of gets
larger and larger the line seems to get more and more busier
Uh near the west edge and you see like most of the people just are just waiting to
Uh, go into this one particular
place as all of the
rooms around this place seems to be pretty much empty
Um, you start walking keep walking keep walking
At one point you start to head outside the gate of the building itself into like this small
little alleyway
and you spot like a small like dingy
broken up kind of
put together a place and
You just hear like one man just fly out the window of this place
As he just lands right in front of you
You
Hello sir
Fuck you
He gets up the ma he like uh
Pat himself of the dirt and everything that he is in and he goes
It gets over the red days way of the heart
I'm gonna I'm gonna rip you apart one day
You turn around and uh keeps going
And all you hear is just next
Uh, and that's it
You see just this line just heading inside a bunch of people
standing in line to enter this room
Uh, you see the scrawny guy kind of
Goes in and he gets like a bit of pushback from the people who are already standing in the line
As the people goes hey, yeah, don't cut in okay, we were here first
Oh
I'm just here to deliver food. I ain't doing anything
We're just here to deliver food
Oh for surveillance heart. Okay. Yeah, of course, of course go in
Uh, you see some of the people in the line kind of like break up as you head inside and in this like dingy like kind of
uh put together
small
room you see a bunch of like just
stacks of papers lying around and this man who kind of resembles his father
No mustache nothing no facial hair, uh, but his hair is like stark black
Uh, with like pointy uh
Things like heading outside like
I don't know like the pointy hair essentially black pointy here
blue eyes and again like a blue like tightly knit clothe um uh coat
With like white shirt uh within
Like a three-piece suit kind of as he's like writing something down for this like woman's
Sitting in front of him as you see like this pieces of glass all over like the place as he flung that guy out
Outside, I mean you don't know who flung the guy outside, but yeah the broken up pieces uh
He's still writing it down something
Uh and you enter the room
I ain't gonna say shit. I'm just gonna follow the scrawny dude
All right, the scrawny dude is just waiting is waiting for uh
cash in to get his work done
He keeps writing something and he goes there you are
Uh, I will meet you tomorrow at the specified time on the schedule
Thank you very much for stopping by
next
And he looks at you uh and goes right how much you'll be what's the name of the client
Uh sir
Sir whale heart
We are I am the head chef of your father. He wanted us to come deliver food to you
He banks the
top of the
His table and goes
I told Jefferson
Do never
Then anything here
This is a place of my work
They do not
Uh mess with my work
Well, this is a Jefferson this is coming straight from your father
I he wanted you to try what my father wanted you to do
I only care
That Jefferson
Listen to my request
Well, you you could take that up with him. I'm sorry
Like right. I'm just doing that as ordered
It's fine. You can
I'm about to take a break either way
He kind of heads outside and he goes
Sorry people
I do have to take a break
Uh, I will meet you here in an hour or so
I will be here to hear your requests
Come back in an hour
And we will continue as
usual
Uh, he like
locks the door slice the door closes it and he sits down
He goes
Right
What is your name?
I haven't seen you before
Are you talking to me sir?
Yes, yes
I'm head chef or borrows
or borrows
Gene
Do you know this man?
He looks at the scrondly dude
Yes, yes, this is new head chef. He he told me how to cook and everything I used to wash dishes before
I know what you used to do, Gene
All right, or borrows have a seat
Yeah, uh, Gene you can take a seat too
Uh, he like takes out
the
lunch box
You still have the piece of paper inside this
Right it would have
Yeah, it would have fallen out as soon as like as soon as
The one dude opens his food like
Oh, assuming like we put it in like some like chopper container thing
Yeah, it's like pin inside the lid of that
So once he listens the lid off of whatever it's going to fall down
Okay, he
Takes a part like the tied up lunch and he
Takes the lid off as the piece of paper slid and outside
He takes a look
Okay, what does it say?
Uh, it would have said like
Son, I need to talk to you. Can you meet me at the end of the docs around
I don't know 9 30. I don't know
837 30 whatever time you want him to go and meet him at the docs
Um, I this is uh, I need to talk to you son. It's urgent. Please meet me
Lotty dot time
Dad
Or no, it's gonna say Lord
Well, huh
Yep, he looks at the known uh, who wrote it? You wrote it?
It would have been me, but I'm gonna do it as nightly neatly as possible
Yeah, he calls rights
I don't
I mean he can write. I don't think he can read or I think it's one of those things. Yeah, he can write he can't read
I don't know how that works, but okay forever
Uh, that's kind of now he looks at the piece of paper and he clearly sees the writing is not his father
He looks at you. He looks at the page. He looks at you again. He looks at the page and he sighs and goes
All right
What do you want air what I don't want anything I was just here to bring you my delicious food
Your dad said you need to try this. This is good his orders. You could even ask
Scraughty man here. He was there. He he saw it all
He like puts his hand in the
Whatever food it is. He like tears it and like chucks it in his mouth as he's chewing goes
Now see I would believe you, but this is clearly not my father's writing
So I'm gonna ask this one more time
What do you want?
Like I said, I'm just here to deliver food and you can even ask
Scraughty man here. I don't know what you're talking about. I was told to come deliver food
We prepared the food. We prepared it for your delivery. I don't know what you're talking about
He looks at this kind of he goes
Jane how long have you known this man?
We just met today sir
All right
Now see
Would you get a fair share of
Nair duels and what not um
You
Do not seem like a
A bad person you taking good care of gene. I did not really like
The other man and
Gene seems to like you so I will give you this one last
chance
To come clearly and
State your business
Like I said, I was hired
To be your guys's new chef because you can fool anyone you like but you can't fool me. I'm a lawyer
I know when you're lying
That's fine. All right
Now
I was hired because your last chef was trash
He he didn't want to admit that his food
Was garbage. I was hired now you could clearly tell that my food is a way better than his
And
We've been all for the last
Three hours we prepared your father's lunch your father told me that
We need to come bring you some food. I don't know why he said come bring some food
Because if you told him never to bring you food it must be because my food is superior than the other chefs
I'm just saying he told us to come bring your food. So that's what we did
I don't know why you keep asking why we're here or what we're here. Take the lid of the lunch and he puts the lid back
He puts arranges the like the
layers of like the top or where ties it up. He slides it over to
Gene and he tells Gene to pick it up. He takes the table right in front of him lifts it up
Consider side gets up and he looks back at you and he's just going to kick you straight in your chest
What the hell
Oh that ain't doing on
Yeah, he takes your straight in the chest and he just like you just completely absorb it and
He looks back at you. He spends around and kicks you again
Well first
Okay, that one hits you the first one you kind of absorb like the impact
But the second kick with the momentum and everything just sends you flying off
the broken window essentially to the ground as he
Kind of jumps out off the window and he goes
I thought I said stop lying
With at this point the the scrawny dude would have been like he's not lying
Yeah, well as far as he knows he's not lying but he's not gonna speak up in front of cashier
Why wouldn't he because he's not in his place
Yeah
Yeah, all right
You want to get into combat
Now I'm gonna be like what is your fucking problem dude like
I'm literally doing what was ordered of me you could ask the scrawny dude. We came here under your father's order
Do not care
Well, who's order you're following I am asking for the truth and you're trying to dodge the truth
Who wrote the letter the letter this letter he takes out the letter
shows it to you
And I'm gonna be like where the fuck did that come from
You size again and he goes
You know
At this point I don't care just leave so I can get back to work
Jane informed Jefferson to kick this person out or whatever position is given and
I'll explain to him later on
You're excused
But you're telling me I'm losing my job for creating you a fine meal
All because there's some letter in there that somebody wrote to you
And you're gonna blame up
Us
scrawny dude was there when we prepared the food to package you
Where the fuck did this letter come from he can attest that I didn't do anything to it
You guys brought me here from my home
I traveled all this way for you just to fire me
Within 30 seconds of you following and me following in order to bring you food
Every word that you've spoken so far has no meaning
There's no base
You understand if he did not witness you put that letter in that doesn't mean you didn't put it in
I'm not a good would I have been able to put it in
He's had the food the entire time since we packaged it. Oh my god. It's like I'm in a corner with a dumbass
Leave me alone. I'm not going anywhere. Whatever your plan is. I don't not care
Just go away. I have a busy dead in front of me
Well, you can have a busy day, but I don't know what you're saying my plan. I'm literally here just to deliver food
Get eight the food now I can go
Yes, and I do not like your face and that's why they're kicking you out. That sounds good to you
That's fine, but you're gonna have to pay for my
For my ship to get back home now
You guys brought me here to cook for you now you're gonna
Send me away. I need a ship
Talk this over with the efforts and I do not care
Jesus
walks inside as
He sits down again
And he just goes next and the line starts to
Continue
As Jean like runs up to you he goes uh, I'm sorry. I could speak up
I was a bit scared that
I'm sorry
You're okay. You're okay. What is your name against her?
Jean my name's Jane. Yeah
Okay, Jean
Do you like this island?
Uh
Kind of so cashians cool
So her cash in is not cool. He just fired me for no reason. I mean
You're kind of dodging his questions
A bit how am I dodging the question? I literally told you what I'm here for I was hired uh
BF chef came to be a chef. That's literally what I did
Uh, like you weren't sorry, but I did not cure an opening for the chef. So uh, um, I just went along. Oh, okay. Oh, okay
Because you currently had a chef they hired me because your other chef sucked
Yeah, okay
The card should be waiting for us in front of the door
All right, okay, he gets up and starts to leave
So we're gonna go out towards there and I'm gonna be like
So this dude just gonna fire me and then expect me to go back to his fucking place
like
You you talk you talk to whoever you want to talk to uh, Jean
If you if you ever want to meet up, I'll be at the local inn waiting on a ship to get the fuck out of here. I ain't going back to his place
If you don't if you ever feel like all right your skills are being squandered. I'll be over there
Uh, all right sir. I should be having heading back
Goodbye him. He starts to run off to
Is there is there anybody around us? Uh, I mean except for the people in the court. No, not really
Okay, so I'm gonna go out to like wherever the thing is and I'm gonna start walking
Like into the woods
Or someplace away from people where nobody can hear
Okay, and I'm gonna and I'm gonna give Baptiste another
tingle I mean you can head inside like
The toilets or whatever in the other place
Well, because I don't want I don't know how loud a dendin moushy is so I don't want
Okay, yeah, you head outside you find like a corner that's like a bit like bushy and like some
Shrubbery around, you know
I can hide inside and give him a call all right
Barbelly
Um, please
Hello
Abos that dude ain't coming he caught on
Something something's going on. I'm just gonna let you know like he is very suspicious
supposedly
Like he caught on I got fired like lie to down this lie to down that but again that court has happened
I met a lovely
Exactly, I got a good look at
Whatever I was supposed to go um, and I'm gonna give him a detailed description of like what I saw
Hmm
So that way he knows like where the area was like what it looked like
Mm-hmm. I'd be like this is what I found this is what I saw
This is I and I'm gonna give him a description of the dude's son so that way he has that
And I'm gonna be like
To make things clear
You just lost our one in with the judge presiding over drove in case
No, Drowvin has no
They are going about this illegaly
He will not have a case. He is literally just supposed to be put to death no trial no nothing
I got fired from a judge who was proceeding over Zim's trial
By by the dude's son
So the dude might come back and hire me back because I told jean where I would be
Roughly
So since I created I created a fantastic meal he might be like you know what fuck my son
I'm gonna need that chef back
Yeah, god Roma okay good
Good work
I would hope everyone so far
Uh Roma is the only one who has made it inside Lexin, puria
What do you I'm just gonna be chilling at the end hoping this dude will come and grab me and find me or
For chilling at the end you have to leave
Lexin, puria and which means you have to go through the marine checkout
Which means you're fucked what they would do
What do you mean I'm fucked
You're fucked
You're literally just saying like
They did not see you they should not see you in the carriage
They did not check the carriage they did not do it
That marine headquarters yeah
Like Roma
Now you have one more person to ask you
My question is is they would they would have seen me walking in with jean
I mean the marine
I mean
They didn't they didn't like like if
The realistically the
Like they won't remember right they don't remember every person who walks in and out
You can try to tell them that yeah, you can try to tell them like you're you're working for whale heart or whatever
But you can try I mean it's up to you
Well
But what I'm saying is is I would have already gotten in they wouldn't be really worried about somebody who's in
Yeah, but like the checkup
Checkup and then saying coming out
I mean it's the same thing
You're moving your hands going
Made in suspect you before because you were with will heart
Yeah
But that's what I'm saying like they would have seen me get out of the carriage
Like some of the guards should have seen me like because if I'm with whale heart
They would have been like oh this dude just left this carriage
So then like the guards at the gate wouldn't know that but I could say that
I was with that and I could be like listen
I just got fired from my job. I'm just trying to get out of here
That no I can't you can try you can try again. You can always try
I'm saying you follow this lake
It's hard yeah, but not gonna be easy
But what I'm saying is they wouldn't really worry about somebody trying to leave if they were already in
It'd be more worried about somebody coming in
I mean do you know it's just that like the
Marines have taken over first specific purpose. They're looking for people
and
You know who they're looking for and they know they're who they're looking for they didn't see you the first time you entered
Is she already on the rise of yeah essentially inside the play there are no guards but
Coming in and out of the place there there are Marines
Especially posted by world
Yeah, but what I'm saying though is they wouldn't really be worried about somebody leaving the place
Yeah, but they if they see a main matching the description of a known criminal they're
Well fucking stop you
That's what I'm saying oh, oh don't worry
Don't worry. I had a I had a I was literally gonna take some
Some of my threads
Like the back of my shirt that's covering my coat and I was gonna put on like
An eye patch and like so I'm not really matching the description, but I still okay, okay, okay
Like it's fine
Again, yeah, I'm fine with the dice without everything
Yeah, like I was just gonna see what they were gonna do
Like
Yeah, I wouldn't even know where to start. Yeah, I mean it's up to you what you want to do. Baptiste you're still on call. It's up to you
Yeah, exactly it'll be all what Baptiste would tell me what to do. Yeah
Our
If you get seen that you run the risk of getting caught
So already been seen by several people
What do you mean you were with other people that gave you a cover?
People about where they keep the first
Sorry, sorry, what are we doing?
So I'm gonna go back
So I'm gonna go back like I said I'm gonna make that disguise like I'm just gonna cover one eye make a weird little eye patch
um
And I'm gonna go get into the line where everybody's lining up to meet that dude because you said it was a super long line
And I'm just going to be in I'm gonna go to the back of the line
And I'm gonna just tap a random person in front of me and be like
Excuse me. Do you know where what this line is for like and
See what they say and then and I'm be like do you know if they
Have visiting hours to the prisoners
So that way because I believe my wife was captured. Ladi Dao this Ladi Dao that
I believed she was captured and I just want to know if I can visit her like
Like where they keep them type thing like
And bullshit and I'll even roll deception and everything
Um the guy looks at you and it just seems to be like some
civilian and you look so pretty sure you go well this the sign goes up to
The the only lawyer that seems to be useful for our kind and he's a good man
And we just want him to represent us in our cases against the world government and you know
Like police with a marine cruelty and so on and so forth in my case the Marines broke into my
job because I didn't pay them the ransom that they wanted to so I want
So cash in to represent me and the zoo the goddamn shit out of these Marines
uh
That makes we can try and get some
reparations for my cause as for the
What a prisoner you want to talk to a prisoner? Well
But most prisoners are held at the basement of the
Lexi Imperial high court building so you should talk to the
I'm talking at the reception though they'll set you up
I did hear like some new prisoners came in and they're especially kept at the
worship their
docked
near the
Darks of Lexi Imperial yeah
Oh, well, my name is John
John and I have a question for you said those are the new prisoners you say yet
Yeah, there's some big shot prisoner. They've been
They brought in like
Yesterday
Today morning. I'm not too sure but it's been in a bunch of rumors going around that it's
some like
Someone learned dangerous so they're keeping them in
The worship itself
Okay, that's all I needed to know because like I'm just trying to figure out where my wife is
Yeah, you're right might be in the the basement area
Okay, okay, I appreciate you and what what did you say your name is again? A John John
All right, I'm gonna reach inside my pockets and I'm gonna like flick him like 10 bellies
Oh, well, thank you very kindly, but we do not take any money for just helping a stranger out
And there you go
I appreciate you. I'm gonna try to go find my wife. You said the basement of the high court correct
Yes, yes, this court if you go to the reception is they will be able to tell you
You need to go to meet the your prisoner
Okay, I appreciate you. Thank you so much. Yes, I walk off. I'm gonna go I'm gonna go find another
alleyway or place and I'm gonna give that piece another
All right
All right, that piece
All right, listen here motherfucker. You go you go
Respect me
Because I'm finding info for you. Okay, you ain't gonna answer like I'm annoying you time shit
First things first most prisoners are kept in the basement of the high court
So y'all need to get here if you guys are trying to get here secondly
gentlemen said there's a bunch of new prisoners high value prisoners that are being kept on their
warship they are not allowed to it to be in the high court okay
It is
prickly
The local prisoners so either them is them and
Whoever the hell we're looking for they're either on the warship or in the basement
What do you need me to do boss
It tight
Whoa sit where the fuck am I gonna sit tight
Where did you say this warship was they said at the dock where they docked the worship that's all they said
He didn't tell me where it is so it's someplace on the island
You know
This will be a good time for somebody to use mirlin to go fly around for us
Marley is not a thing anymore. We have one of
Yeah, he doesn't have a fine family anymore. Yeah
He doesn't have any orders and he has a horse
We have one of two options
One
Return to the ship and we ambushed their warship with our ship
Warships my might I add there were a lot of warships
I'm not just saying there's one warship
And we don't have weapons. Yeah
Which you could have gotten you could have gotten a lot of weapons for 50 million belly
We didn't have time
I mean you could have I said it for weapons and everything you could just say whatever
Or
We
Find way to get through the
Check point
Meet up with you and then
We enter from land
Either way we have to make our way to the warship
Yeah
So you literally want me sitting in an alley digging through trash
Tell you all figure out what you want to do
Hmm
Let me do it inside check
You said check on who
What the situation okay
Yeah, the situation right now is looking very fucked
Okay, if joking I said what do you want to understand about the situation? What do you think? Do you
One are of the 21 are best
Get what get to Zim somehow
Yes
As often now
Here are you're like realistically your options somehow find your way inside
Lexi in period first of all you have to get to Lexi in here if you want to have any contact with them
There's two ways to handling this either
you
maybe
Like rescue her during her
deposition or whatever like her case
Wherever whenever the trial is you can try to rescue her maybe you can try to
uh
Rescue her in between that first of all the problem is getting inside
You know what I can come
Dravels
Just done all this inside
Yeah, the dravels is out of yeah, he's out in picture for now. I mean it's gonna take a while for him
Recurver I have an idea he's been using his powers for like three weeks straight never three times straight back
I know grab my tendon machine uh-huh
In contact the
Radio that I had with them
Okay, okay, okay, that's a bulzy move
Okay
All right
Um, but these
All right, fuck me
All right you
ring the radio machine and
It's soon like just
You hear static coming from the other line
Uh, so it's open whatever you are saying is going to be heard by whoever's on the other land
I know you're there. They're all around
Highlands nothing up
Still static coming through
Yeah
Every minute that you ignore me one of your precious lawmakers
Well, let's just say things won't be going
Move the event
You want to touch my people
I think it's only fair that some people in your end get touched as well
I'll touch people that taste that's creepy
All right, yeah continue continue
Dingle like to mouth is to make a noise in the background
Oh
As you make that noise some guy like close by he goes you're given
Oh just ignore
You
The you hear a click and on the other side you hear
Little bird decided to show up after all
Right then you think I want to do it this way
With all the onlookers to word the colesto incident and with the armor malfunctions
You have a lot of eyes on us go ahead get rid of these panties for all I cared will make my job easier
Next week, it's gonna be draves and I'm gonna make sure along with
Sorry, droven
Along with droven your friend here also gets
The same punishment no matter what I have to do to achieve that
I will see you around baptize
I'm sure we are destined to meet again
Now that's not ruined this moment by contacting each other again
I will not be picking it up next time
And you hear a click and just static
I
I am truly
Call them back
That
Be like you don't hang up on me I hang up on you
If he also is looking to excuse them as well at st. Thomas droven
I mean it's up to you what you want to do
Do we still hang up on the execution again
Next week next week and I mean it's
We don't know the result of what is the decision of
Them like what happens to her if she's going to be sent to prison is she's also scheduled for
Yeah, but there's like other factors in this not up to him
Yeah
At this point that she's like you're saying it because he can't figure out anything so he just yells
Everyone around kind of looks at you and goes
You're right man
As the same guy is the same guy is just walking around and just telling everyone you are right man
Is this a crazy person there is nothing you really even asking a question
This is gonna be really bad mouth this
Yeah
Don't follow me in what I'm about to do
What do you mean?
A man who just asked if I'm all right
All right go ahead
Roll for damage
Did you leave him into the other first or just on the streets just in the middle of the fucking tutorial
15 and 16 what do you want to do knock him out or kill him
I'm just knocking him out
Okay
you
Just in your frustration just look at him and just fucking punch him straight in the face
He goes flying over to the other side of the cathedral and boom
All the ice turn around look at you and just panic
Panic and zoos and everyone starts running you hear the Marines kind of looking over and
Like clocking their guns toward where the noise came from because of like the crash
There's a bunch of dust right now in the air. So no one has like a clear view of what is happening
What do you want to do?
I'm not gonna walk through dust
Oh
And all the Marines are like closing in pointing their guns towards you. There you go
I say fucking creepy dude
Who's like a squirrel here now
Man of rural with the hell are you supposed to be
Whichever guard to set that I'm charging at him
Okay, roll roll for damage. I'm sorry attack attack
My god Jesus Christ it's gonna get you all killed
Yep, okay rolls of damage
You
Yeah, you want to kill him?
You just fly up to him like like dash up to him and just from smack his head in and
You look at the other garden just save Warro and he like his gun at this point. It's just shaking as he goes
Uh, I think we should call
Gavin Warro and
The other guy just takes a dent in motion and starts raining incessantly and on the other line you just hear
what
And he just says
There's there's someone who wants to
Talk to you
Oh
Okay, I'll be there
um and
Clicked it off and all the Marines at this point start gathering all the way around
Right now at this point in the middle of the cathedral you just five Marines pointing their guns towards you
Uh, you're just standing in between
Yes
Where where are they surrounding him is my question like at the gate like what I be
You know he's in the cathedral you're very far away. Yeah
Yeah
Okay in the cathedral
What's the cathedral made of
It's like white stone limestone whatever
It's pretty sturdy that it's like it's at all the length
Are they closing in on me or are they just no no no no no no just around with the gun there they're pointing their guns at you they're far away
Far away
Yeah, you dashed into one of the dudes pretty far away how far are they?
Maybe like 40 50 feet
Why can you bring all
No
They're just pointing at you because you killed two people
I didn't kill anyone
Yeah, whatever mock them out as far as they're concerned he's dead
That's surrounding me yeah, I would like to like
Pain that I'm giving up so they all start closing in
No
The needle down I feel like you're kneeling down you're kneeling down are you sure
Yeah, okay, you're kneeling down
One of the dudes just walks in it's still keeping his
Gun up and he takes out like these pair of cuffs behind him and this one this one
Yeah, he started to walk up as he signals to everyone else like shoot
As soon as you see any movement yeah
Missles there's five of them yeah
How close are they to each other
Uh, I mean, it's pretty big cathedral. They're pretty spread apart so you don't like escape or something
Okay, what let's use our characters as like a
Okay, yeah, probably like 15 feet or something
Like this
Let's take this as like uh
Yeah, it's like this it's like a star shape
And the guy in front is approaching you
Like this slowly okay, okay
Okay, yeah, uh, he's gonna approach you it takes out a piece of cuff
Uh, and he like puts the gun on his shoulder and starts to approach you. Yeah
Um
As he gets closer
Mm-hmm how close I'm worth
10 feet
5 feet 10 feet yeah, okay, he's 10 feet close
I am going to like turn my head back to look at these two
Uh-huh
Moda pal
Yeah
Place it on top of them
All right, there's gonna be people running around as well. I mean, I guess they have cleared out
But you might catch some people
Yeah, okay, all right
Uh, okay, Moda pal
Uh, just your flame just engulfs this whole place
And it starts to burn them
Uh, all right, let me put everyone in combat
All right, let me see
They have their action ready by the way, so they're gonna shoot as soon as you pull something
So I hope you survive this
Miss
Not 20
deflect missiles count in this situation like some
It would it would it would yeah
Roll
So 11 so that's two damage for the first one
I mean, it's good. That's a good that you deflected the fucking that 20
Uh
Seven there we go and then we got two fires and then two more
Where are you at this point mouth is
Are you away with the crowd
Uh
Five eleven so that's
Uh, so that's four one more
Okay, we're disappointed
Yeah, yeah, they were
Yeah, none none of the others hit all of the bullets just go
Straight through you and the guy in front of you also panics and puts pulls out a gun and straits
Shoot you like straight in the head, but again, it goes through straight through you
Uh, one of them kind of nicks comes close to you and you grab it and just throw it away
Uh, all right
What what is happening it's your turn all of them will have their turn at the same time
The two that got put in the model for hell they take 14 fire damage
14 fire damage yeah, they're dead
They burn right in front of everyone
And at this point the crowd is like really in true panic everyone who was working on the thing they've
platformed they've all run off everyone's left the cathedral and you just hear a bunch of panic going outside and
Malthus as you're also leaving with the crowd as you keep an eye on the situation
you see a lot of lot more Marines kind of like
Walking in from like different parts of the place as the seat panic
All right
What are you doing about please?
I'm sorry towards the front of me
Okay
Um punch
Yeah, I mean you can roll damage, but he's gonna die the way
Yeah, if you roll minimum, I think you're gonna yeah 15 is no yeah 15 is able to knock everyone out as long as you had
Okay, you knock this one out
Yeah, I'm talking about um
Move oh
No, that does not have
The one more
That hits
Yeah
There's one more left okay for that
That was 20 feet to get there yeah, you can meet 20 feet more. I still have
Yeah
Let's just use three attacks
Come on blurry
Okay one more
Well, two more two more right?
No one more he uses one more he used the bonus yeah, yeah, look
I need the plan
I almost damage the right either on our strike do not not a fire on big
Yeah, I think I would have to get back sandwich
Um
I mean it's a D it from a more deep I'm pretty sure
Yeah
Yeah, it's gonna hit it. Yep
All right, you knock all of them out, but you also see
From the entrance of the cathedral more Marines entering the place
Which way is the entrance is it this way
This way and like it's a very narrow entrance
Maybe like five to six people can fit in only and all of them will like line up as the crowd is kind of
pushing them as they're trying to leave
So they will have a hard time this will consider as a difficult terrain I guess
All right
While that's happening I would like to run into the crowd
Mm-hmm
And then we're just gonna
You
Miss this step
Boyd step
Art essentially
Okay, can you make a stealth check so
Uh, no one notices you essentially
He's disappeared again
He's just appeared again
He's gone to different dimensions
Yeah, it's good. What the fuck is happening?
28 yeah, you essentially like burst in
flame at one point you punch the hell out of the guy in front of you dash punch the hell out of the other guy
Dash punch the hell out of the other guy and just run in
White step just
Your body like completely melts in the dimension as the space between the wall and you closes up
You appear right around the part where malphous was standing behind the guards and you appear right in front of him or behind him near
Our malphous you want to kill this man?
I was so close to going in
I'm just getting in the crowd now
All right, uh, you see the marines are like looking for
whoever made the
Thing and they're like trying to log down the cathedral the short doors kind of shut back
Um and the people are still like running away and everything
Uh Roma at this point on your end
Uh, you uh over here like a bunch of people
uh starting to panic and you hear like a blast coming from the direction of the cathedral that you were at and a bunch of marines are starting to mobilize and get into like
The small ships around the bridge as they're trying to
Had to do so
And you see a different kind of armor you've seen the armor from spare clefs but the one that you spotted right now is a different sort of armor
Oh shit
And I'm only seeing like how many guards a lot of marines marines like a lot like normal uniform marines and then a different platoon of like
Uh warship is just like
Splitting away from the warships that you see like docked at one of the docks of the island and you see one of the
ships just leave
And that's it on the deck of the ship you spot that armor you form a farmer
Okay
And I'm just seeing
All of these people running towards the dock what I have happened to see the dock the the you know the other island
Yeah, go ahead
What I happen to see any warships
Yeah, one one of the warships again you at if you're near the bridge
Uh, like near the entrance of the high court the the second island is essentially
All just like mostly the high court and nothing much else except for like the mountains and everything around the
island
Near the edges you can spot like all the warships that are lined up to the island and the warships are pretty big
So you can easily spot them from distance
Moving in
Okay
so
I'm gonna go back into that line of people
Would they have still been standing there or they starting to freak out?
Uh, I mean they
Are like kind of like spread apart. They've bloke in the line itself and like looking onwards as to what is happening
They're not really panicking because it's like pretty far away
From where there are but yeah, they're just looking around and
Okay, what do I still see that guy that I was talking to?
Yeah, yeah, you see John
Okay, so
I'm gonna I'm gonna ask him to be like hey John
I went I saw my wife
um
She she told me I would have to talk to the lawyer to see if I could get him to plead her case
But I noticed she mentioned those warships that have those high value prisoners
Do you see it around here so that way I know to avoid it because like I am not trying to
upset anybody but like if I go ask questions like where they're
um
Where I could talk to the
Other lawyer just to see if I can find one because you said there's only one but I just there's got to be another someplace
I just don't want to piss anybody off. Do you know where anybody like that like where I could avoid like
Hey, I just don't want to piss anybody off
Yeah, I mean
Well, there are a lot of warships day. We don't nearly
uh, no one really knows where the prisoners are kept
There's just a lot of warships. I'd say use day away from all of them. Yes
Oh, but like is there one worship that has stayed put the entire time?
And except for the one warship that's leaving all of the warships were pretty much here from the way get gone
Okay
That's all I needed to know
I guess I'll just wait in line or I'll
I'll go do something until the line gets smaller
Well my friend and this line never gets smaller
So the cashier is a famous line never gets smaller
Uh, more people need to have these today
All right then
Okay, thank you so much. I mean if you stay in the line of course you're gonna get in first
But you know if you come back in there basically they're gonna be the same line. That's what I'm saying
I can save you a spot if you need that's fine now go
Yeah, that'd be perfect that'd be perfect just save my spot. I'm just gonna go
I'm gonna go talk to my wife again and tell her that's going to be a while
It's all right
So cashier move that you're free, you know
Whatever your rice crime is and sure sir cashier can be a little bit
All right, so
I am going to
The high court is there a lot of
Guards there right now again inside the court you don't really see a lot of marine presence
Outside the court is very heavily heavily guarded like all around
So how where would I go to get to the
The basement to like you go to the receptionist yeah in the center of the high court
You must see like some sort of receptionist at the center
Helping people like navigate where they need to go stuff like that
Fuck
Go up I need to figure out
I need to go there and I'm just gonna talk to her and be like I'm here to talk to the prisoner about the petty theft that he happened to
Have a supposedly occurred
Okay, you can ask that but you will have to give her name
Right
Well, and then I'm gonna be like
John sent me because
He is currently talking trying to talk to the lawyer about rep
Reparate reparations for the damages marines caused and he believes that she they are witness
I don't know the exact person name him
I just know his charge was petty theft
Like I just need to talk to him I'm just gonna ask questions
Be a bit more specific other than that have you have around a 2000
Um the prisoners for the case of petty theft which one do you wish to meet?
Um, whatever one that happened at john's shop
Because John's shop, but do you know the name of the shop?
No, I just the owner of his name was John and he said he's trying to get a hold of the lawyer
I'm just trying to help john out like I didn't get a last name
I just met him in line and he said that there was a criminal that happened to be at the shop at the time that these
Marines caused damage to his shop
So I was just gonna call I was just gonna come and ask
Simple questions like if they saw anything if they happen to know which marine guards cost the damage
Only allow them to meet their either their lawyers or family members
So you can bring this john person and they can meet them themselves
Okay, okay, I'll be right back. So I'm gonna go up to john
I'm gonna go back to john and be like hey john
You mentioned that you had a store that was damaged due to marines
I thought
I found out there may be some criminals that were in your shop at the time
I just need you to come with me
And tell this lady that there may have been criminals at the time that this happened that may be witnesses to the marines causing damage to your shop
It looks okay. Can you roll a persuasion?
Oh my god if this fails
You're a persuasion
Come on baby come on baby. Oh shit
Nice
Okay, he kind of looks confused, but he
Maybe feels like okay, and there might be a chance someone to witness the thing and he goes
Uh-oh all right all right. Hey back. Can you um, uh save the space for the two of us
The guy in front of the line goes all right
Very going to believe
He's like no no, I'm going to visit one of the prisoners and he might have witnessed the
Um, the the marines roughing up the place. This is this is and what was your name again?
Or a boroughs. This is mr. Herbos. He's he's helping me
Uh, you see the
I'm kind of an institute and yeah
I was just told that there may have been a criminal. That's why the guard
So we're there at the shop to fuck something up
It is he
All right then let's go
And I just I just overheard that
Okay, so I'm uh he goes up to the receptionist he goes and I love that I
I have to meet these two criminals two one one two
I don't know I heard the right there might be some criminals who witnessed the uh the
Trashing of my shop at Beckins Beach
And I I want to get to
They got a sort of a statement so I can show mr. Keshe and that um
The this uh these people are the witness and she looks at the chart
Um, I'm gonna roll a 120 to check if it actually goes for not it might be a coincidence, you know
No, so that's good. Uh, she looks at the chart and she goes
Huh, I do see two imprisonments from the Beckins Beach area um yeah now write this way if you take a left down there
Uh, go left and then take a right um a third seller from there. Yeah
Uh, I'll send a
Yeah, you will find a guard accompany you within the place and uh just tell him the these two names
um morose and
genie
morose and genie
Okay, I appreciate you. I'm not sure which one of them witnessed your thing but you can talk to them in the witch book
Here you go. These are your peices and she hands out like two paths you
And let's go mr. Robos as he is now I'm gonna start following
Uh, you see uh as you like had downstairs
Uh in the basement you see a guard standing in front of like these
Uh, sell doors essentially and he stops you and he goes
passes
Hello
You we gonna show them the passes. Okay, you show them the passes. He takes a look at them looks at you and goes right then you're all good
Open it up and you hear ching and the gate opens up and you are allowed to head inside
What I
What I have seen where this would have been where this would have happened like is there a control room like yeah
There seems to be like the camera is like a dented moushi pointed upwards that are looking downward towards you
Okay
Yeah on the signal of the guard they open the thing and as soon as you enter you hear another ching and the door closes
be like
jail cell whatever
And you see them him like kind of
Going to the room
That the criminals supposed to be what are you doing? Where what is your plan?
I am looking for
For like a control tower like if there is one
In the cell it's just like always it's just always with like jail cells and that's it
It's like oh again, it's all underground
Yeah, there's gotta be a place that controls all the cells like yeah, but it's not necessarily at the same place right
It will
Typically it is like there's gotta be a master
I'm probably but you you have to look around but
What are you doing with John? You leaving John? Where is going away? I will avenge I will eventually like
I'm gonna pretend to tie my shoe and then John will go to where he's supposed to go and I'm just gonna start looking around like
Okay, uh you take a ride and you take a left and this like it's just like a labyrinth of just
Cell, softer cells after cells after cells after cells and at the other end you do see like kind of like
Light coming through one of the corridors and seems to lead outwards somewhere
Is it just like a normal metal door? Is it like?
Uh again, it's just it's just blinding light because like these always are pretty dark
So you just see a blinding light you can't really look at like what exactly is going on there
Okay, so I'm
Uh
I'm gonna go in there like just guys still on
I'm gonna go in there and if I find somebody I'm gonna pretend like I got lost because I had to bend down in time
I shoe and that's what it's gonna look like on the camera. Okay
you
head out and
uh
You just see a guard kind of like eating his
um like lunch or something and
Hi, are you here?
You get lost or something he puts down his like uh food and he gets up
He takes out like his beer and everything goes well off you go
Go back where you came from
Well, uh, what's through there like I'm just trying to get out like I was here with the buddy
I lost him. I'm assuming I had a like time I shoe and I lost him he he kept going without me jackass. He is
um
Like I'm just trying to get out while I'm while I'm like talking to him
I'm also like quickly scanning to see if like there's any cameras or anything in this room
Can you do a quick perception?
Yes, and I'm also looking to see if he's the only guard
in here
Perception
Come on baby
Oh, that's not bad
um
This seems like sort of like a break room for the guards or
Or something like that
But around the
Room uh to you it doesn't really seem like any you don't spot any dendon moushies and this guard is the only one that you see in front of you
But they could be more okay
So again, I'm just trying to find the exit is it through there and I'm gonna like take a step
Oh, it's a special prison escort you can go back where you came from
What do you mean special like I'm not I'm just nosy like what do you mean special prison escort
Like is it my enjoy on business fella who are you here to meet show me your pass
And then I'm and then I'm gonna show them the pass, but I'm gonna I'm gonna turn around
Like because he told me to leave like I'm just gonna hold the pass up and then put it down turn to leave and then turn around
Be like hey, I didn't notice you were eating something do you want something that's a little bit better than that like
And then pull out one of the pocket treats that I got
It's gonna taste a lot of a lot better than that moush you're eating
All right, let's give it a try add it over
And he takes a bite
Now I'm gonna walk over because like you said like even when I
Did a quick turnaround. I'm still looking to see if there's cameras. Yeah, I want me to do another perception
Like do it with the banish this and yeah
Okay
So like I'm just doing a quick
Little look just making sure there's oh shit, but I
Um you look around again this time you do spotted a door leading into this room
On the right side and you do spot a camera on top of that corner
Keep not camera you know then and moush just looking at you
Okay, so then
So no camera just a dendin moush that would
No like just essentially like the dendin moush looks through and it displays on whatever like screen
Yeah, there are camera dendin moush's yeah
That's that's that's what I needed to know like if it was like one of that you just talked into like
No, no, it's a camera
Okay, so then I'm just gonna be like oh yeah, here you go dude like
Go ahead and try this, but can you come out in the hallway and show me where I'm supposed to go
He takes a bite and I'm
That's very good. It's pretty I do have more of these I
Yeah, I got a couple more but like
Yeah, I just all right animal work figure out where the hell I'm supposed to go
Well, whoa, whoa, whoa, I ain't just gonna give you I just gave you one so you could have it now
You try to take me all of it from me
You know, well, I'm escorting you out I'm helping you and you can repay this kindness by giving me some food
Okay, okay, well
All right come show me all right, man, you hand him thing he takes his like original like
Food that he was eating I'm not gonna hand it to you yet. I'm gonna have him come out into the hallway with me
We're like he takes like the half-bitten piece of like bread that he was eating and he just shoves it in like one of the
baskets
Like trash baskets near the door and goes all right, let's go
And he walks outside the room behind you
With his beer and everything
And I'm gonna I'm gonna pretend to give him a biscuit
And such like I'm gonna accidentally drop it like as
How is that how are you doing? You're ruining this is very well good a five-second rule you grab it real quick
As soon as he bends over pants mash back to the head uh a little bit advantage
All right
Yeah, and hits
So a 20 hits so wouldn't that be critical?
No, no, no, you have to roll a 20 anything great yeah
I don't remember naturally 18 19 20 essentially
11 let me see yeah that was exactly okay. Okay
Yeah, go ahead
So I'm gonna knock him out and then
I'm going to try to take as much of his armor that will
Fit probably nothing
Probably not a lot but except for like the helmet essentially the hat
Whatever the head
What he's stripping him
And I'm sure he should out of him and I'm okay he has to have like
He has to have like keys to sell or something. Yeah, yeah, he has key so
So I'm taking it I'm taking his idea. I'm taking everything that he has
on him and I am
Rowing him in a cell
He's taking his virginity a okay, you open like an empty cell
You know what can you roll the d20 for me?
Yes, sir
Just normal d20 normal 20. I want to see if you open an empty cell on
Yeah, yeah, you should be able to open an empty cell you open an empty cell in your shabby man
Lock the door and where you headed
You're gonna laugh, but I'm gonna go back to that room
Where he's just that okay, and
I am just have a question in any of his gear is there a map that shows
Where like certain certain
Quarter doors are like jailhouse was the show where he troll is he won't need any
He's like a worker, so he's probably pretty familiar with it
But cuz like
Yeah, cuz
Most when he was in the break room he wasn't out of desk. Oh, it wasn't breaking. Oh, so he was a desk at the
Cuz the only reason I say that is most security guards keep like a little map of the place
Of like all the different cell areas because if there's 2000 cells
Like you have like something
Can you look into the lockers maybe
That's what out that's yes roll for roll for investigation
Perfect
There's gotta be something someplace that's showing the map of this place
investigation
By the way, but he's there just wanted to ask all of this time. Did you have
Lou on you?
See I was gonna say something
When I told mouth is not to get involved with what I was about to do I would yeah
Yeah, you probably would have handed Lou over just so he doesn't get killed in the book and
Full chat. Okay, I just want to make sure when I'm dashing around. Oh, you're
Fucking wolf is having a panic attack
Six now, I don't think you should be you would be able to find anything in his lockers or anything
You don't you were not able to find his specific locker. He didn't he didn't have anything on himself
There may be something on his his locker, but you don't know his name so you can't figure out which one exactly like
Yeah, and then of the lockers that you open had any map
Okay
Is there the Denon mushy do I see wires coming from the ceiling running along?
It's like mostly magic so there's no wires. I don't think in one piece
You
Damn
This would be perfect if I had detect magic because then I can figure out where the fucking spells were coming from. Yeah
I guess
I don't know I'm gonna have to start randomly fucking walking
I mean there you see two exits out of the room the one exit is
Essentially where you knocked him out that exit and the other exit that I pointed out that he said it was
like a special escort entrance for prisoners
Okay, well, I'm gonna go back into that jail
Oh, yeah, and every cage
But the one that I threw that dude in I am unlocking it and
Thing basically saying oh prisoners are free
Saying to who the prisoners
Yep, you're free to go
Okay, so we're doing a jailbreak. Okay cool um
You're also on top of that. I'm asking them where the master control room is
Everyone that you free
Essentially just shoves you away and just starts running to the exit
They're not gonna look or wait for anyone or anyway. There's fucking riding is out
uh, and
They essentially like start to beat on the
um
door okay, let me see if
Uh, did you unlock the door that uh, he was standing in front of
John
All right, you go up to John's door
uh
Can you make a one D20 to see if he recognizes you or not
Basically this guy's check for this case
Yeah, he definitely recognizes you it looks like you
Mr. Burr so why are you dressed like that
Sorry dude
back of the head
And he passes out immediately
Uh, you unlock the door that he was talking to and you keep going keep going keep going and you lock all of the doors you
Do not season first of all and the prisoners are starting to like
uh
put like the essentially like break down the main cell door as
They're like overpower the guard and start to leave outside uh, and now we have a full-on riot on our hands
Okay, I'm gonna move back to that piece before the situation gets out of trouble
All right
Matisse, Malthus, what is happening
Well, first I'll burn a bit for the way i'm hitting with pushing him in the head
Yeah
All right
Well
Well, Vorro is on his way now now we just wait
Uh
Then
Then I read that old school from before
All right um you um
As like everything everyone's panicking and everything happening you see like a bunch of marines
Leave the cathedral as they like take out like big denim moushi like microphones as they start speaking into it
And they bring out like a poster and it's you of course and they go
Attention all civilians
If you have seen this individual around you will have to report this to the marines
There is a reward even for information
What
Nothing okay and uh they pull out more posters and essentially it's like everyone from your crew and they go
Each one of these individuals is very dangerous and wanted all throughout the world
Any information about them will get you rewarded
And so on so forth like they're just spreading these uh posters and everything and
All of the people are now where they'll still say scrap all acceptance yes
Yes, the scrub but I guess it's whatever
Yeah
All right, so uh you're just waiting where are you waiting this is essential
It's probably still close edge to the cathedral where we can still see something but
out of sight
All right, I'll say like near like a big uh like forced area
Yeah, yeah, what was about to say that
I mean, you could just jump you could just jump man. It's not like you're fucking
useless
Uh
You should be able to like locate yourself like basically prone on one of the roofs near the cathedral and yeah
should be able to
Stay there
um
in about like
uh
few like 30 to 40 minutes you see a bunch of
Like
Marines like walking around the whole town
They're searching for someone and essentially they like
Some of the Marines rush in the center and talk to some other Marines as
Some of them now leave and go to word the direction of like
Imperia now start to move in there and a few Marines are still here looking
Uh, and you hear like a big like caravan walking in the caravan kind of like mechanical car kind of situation
It's like a carriage like self-driven carriage whatever with wheels and everything as it like rolls in
Uh, you see you were stepping out of the caravan as he
looks around and
He brings in some of the Marines that were
Uh in the place
Uh and confronted you when everything and maybe looked at you as he's talking with them. He's looking around the the place
Uh, he
Kind of calls in
Different set of armor that you've never seen before he kind of walks in behind him as he kind of whisper something into his ear
As the armor now starts to like boost up and starts to fly up in the sky
In the time that we were waiting can I have did a short rest?
Uh, maybe 30 minutes yeah, sure
Hmm
Also take more shows that you'll be back at full. Yeah, sure
I could probably use the six HP. Yeah, yeah, I did
My one's back
Uh as the armor starts to fly up you see more armored Marines start to show up
Uh possibly from the
Essentially like the the orange that you hear from
Far away of the battleship
That just landed on this island and you see a like
range of Marines like first class Marines
Recruits in the same armor that you faced before as they're like starting to circle like the whole island. They're starting to like
trash the
Surroundings and like the shops and everything they're shutting everything down kind of like putting everything in a curfew
The day is kind of
falling slowly
And it's maybe like around two or three p.m
Yeah
Yes
very much so
I've already know we're pretty much surrounded by Marines
You think?
One thought in my head is the infiltrate
His carriage
Yeah, okay, I mean he's inside the carriage. He's waiting. He's just waiting for more intel
He's sitting in the carriage right now. Yeah
Is this carriage only people are around his carriage like you see like
Like maybe like a battalion maybe like 12 or something people around in an arm maybe like close distance
It's not that far away
But they're just like looking and like
You know in the middle like the right-in-front look at you real in the square in the town square essentially where all the shops are is there
So it'd be difficult to try to enter his carriage unnoticed. Yeah
Well at least one last fight
Yeah, let's just throw it all away for for one girl
Men
Well, but this is also a driven I mean yeah, but drawing is in the future
If you don't make it out of that and drawments fucked
Yeah, this is also a driven. Yeah sure sure you can say that to convince yourself
Oh, what I don't know what to do. You guys
You put it in this situation
Oh, I did
You literally you guys had no plan whatsoever right
Okay
All right, what are you doing?
Um
We haven't been spotted yet, right doesn't look like we'll be spotted if we stay where we are
I mean the flying suit is now in the air so if you maybe move around you might spot you you don't know
I'll pull out the dinner machine to contact Bolo
Contact oh the same dinner mushi the radio okay
Okay, you you can speak into it. It's not like it's a connection. It's just you know a radio you speak
He hears
Oh
As soon as you say that you
See him step outside of the thing as he like with his two fingers. It's like pointing it up and looking at it
And his like other fist is just like you see him like actually getting pretty mad
What's wrong
Are you there
He's still awaiting looking at the dinner mushi you can see him just waiting
Oh
He kind of face bombs and he goes
clicks late the end of the mushi holds it close to his face and goes
What I thought we decided not to talk to each other before
We needed to rest
Why you still scared little bird you face me add on
Come on
I think you're scared to face me
That's funny because you're the one hiding away when I'm right here
You can see me right
And come on
I can also see
That you didn't come alone
What's more becower's way than using numbers
Yes, and I suppose you are here all by yourself
Correct
That's not I do have one other person hold the pissing content
Let's just get over what do you want
You're not getting her you know what I lie
You're not getting him alive the only way out of this is you
With me in a cell
I can torture you forever
Like the good old days
I know you're obsessed with me, but I don't see you that way
Oh you will you will wonder
You stand
What your position is in this world
a worm and
most like your kind
Only useful to us
Further
our technology
Our progress my comodores
rules and ambitions
Once I have you
as well
Be a good little boy
And kill these Marines like you did the ones before for me
They now come out
You don't have a leverage at this point about these
And I don't throw away my men for nothing
The 9 million that you gave me really help you did go
You mean the chunk change
Haha, just because you have 130 million bounty don't think you're a hot shot
You understand me little bird I can crush you with just my thumb
If not see you try
Send everyone else away
Just you take of me as a fool do you
I'm a man my word
If you
Have working for you in Lexington
Is also going to get captured
And all the prisoners that fled are going to be put down
And the Lexington
You have overstepped your bounds so much
Let it bird you have no idea
The higher ups are not happy
But you meddling with the judiciary
And we will use everyone in our power to crush you
I only got authorized for bringing the low marine levels
Now I'm bringing in someone else
Through layers
See how you get out of this alive
At least you'll be going down with me
Let's see about this one after all right
Oh, I want you
Impresent
Once I figure out who that other one is
He's going down with you
The little bitch didn't say a thing about you should be
Glad
The only reasons she's alive is that she didn't
Snitch
It's not useful so I'll get rid of her
And she acted like good bitch you know
I thought I had a use for you
No, I just thought of a new one
I think you'll love it too
When I take you down
You're going to be my new little play thing
I'm going to hang up
As you hang up he gets frustrated
He like throws the then the moushi down and just crushes the thing with his leg
And he bangs on the
Caravan and he looks at one of the Marines grabs him, pulls him up
He yelled something at him and just throws him away as he gets inside
And he just starts the
Car or whatever the thing is and just like speeds it
And just leaves
Towards like the novel district or whatever like judge district that you came from
I would like to try to follow
Okay
Can you roll stealthy?
That was what are you doing?
Also following
On foot are in the air for you Melodies
Uh, I mean jumping roofs from these deals
Okay
Old stealth both of you
All right
Okay, all right
Okay, uh
Baptiste you are light you are not that heavy and you are kind of agile
So you are able to jump with the roofs just fine
Malfa's you try to jump from the first roof that you can
As you land on the other roof
It just immediately collapses and you just falls straight down
All of the Marines here the commotion and they start running toward you
That's what you're doing
I'm taking my dog and keep going
Okay, yeah, fuck him
All right
Okay, okay, go ahead, go ahead
Um, all right
Yeah, so all guests
Uh, essentially, it's just like a collapsed roof and you were like at the base of it
But there's to like smoke and everything in the air
The Marines are like kind of closing in that they're like enforcer rifles
As they're moving in and just pointing in the shadows
Is you see like all these like lasers coming through the smoke pointing towards you
Uh, is there a window on the other side of like the
You can just go straight up where the hole you fell down from
Yeah, I'm going to it and going into full sprints
Okay, uh, dash catch up at puppies
Okay, yeah, I'll catch up with puppies at this point
I mean they're going to see you that's not the point right
Well, and yeah, move
Either you hide
You can take the action to hide yeah, all right, so 60 feet and then hide
essentially
Do stealth again
Go again, I don't ask for much
All right, yeah, uh as you like jump up essentially from the
um
From the like broken off roof the like wave of just
Dust just goes through with the shockwave that you just lifted off as everyone like
points their guns backwards and just looks at the roof you're just gone because you would like just
Went up and straight towards Baptiste
Uh, okay, you
See mouth is like catch up to you Baptiste as you're trying to follow
Uh, borrow
All right time for a perception role
Oh my god
Okay, um
Do you have any items that uh, let's you check for danger now, right?
No
I got eyes
Uh, all right
Oh, Belle, I see what
Oh that bell that uh, collage gave you, right
The bell oh, no, no, no, not that bell. Okay, never mind. It's not that
The bell fragment yeah, you can just re-roll for that. It doesn't let you know like danger or whatever
You can use it, but
uh
If you want to make them re-roll the perception check
Then I can do that if you want to do that
Okay, if something happens
Yeah, yeah, I guess
I'm just gonna take the best of the way
Okay, okay
I'm just selecting which one of you gets shot out of the air. Okay, it's Baptiste
Um
I'm what? What am I reading?
Oh, you died. Oh, no, that's not that's not that's not the thing. It's just like I chose you and Malfus to pick one
It's just the role of failure. The the prefixes don't really matter
Well, that's one way
All right, while Malfus joins us uh, Roma what is happening at your end
So
Free to everybody yes
Um, what the fuck Baptiste died
No, no, no, no, no
It's just um
I freed everybody. There's mass chaos. There's fucking riots
so
Well, I am gonna dip back to that area where he said special delivery
Thanks
Okay, okay, special like escort for prisoners. Yeah, okay. Yeah, go ahead
Uh, I'm gonna use his keys to go through
Okay, do you shut the door behind lock the door or do you just want to leave it open?
I'm gonna leave it wide open. Okay, uh, you leave it wide open. You uh basically leave through you see a bunch of like prisoners that escape earlier
Are trying to now go through this route as well. They just shove you away and just fucking move
Upwards and downwards. There are two servers leading downwards in the one upwards
I'm back. I'm back. All right. I am going to go
Fuck what's happening? I have switched to Roma for a while. Let's
Let's uh
Even goes up down or odd goes down. Let's find out looks like we're going up
All right, you start to head up the stairs. You see some of the prisoners kind of like run past you
Uh, and get up
Uh
What you see outside of these chambers is basically an entrance to the
um
Essentially the courtroom
Where like the process happens and you just see a bunch of like criminals running around with like
Uh, the spears that they took from the guards and just like stab a bunch of like
People that were around in the area and whatever and just like taking people hostages is there like kind of leaving
Uh, the place and threatening the like the guards that are already there um and so on
So then I'm gonna turn around and go downstairs
Okay, uh, yeah, they're causing chaos
Yeah, yeah
In short walking down you see more prisoners kind of like leading you're still in guards uniform, right
No, just just like the half ass helmet like oh, well, okay, but they should realize that I'm the one that let them out like yeah
They probably saw you uh, okay, so the no one can mistake you okay
So you go down downwards you go through the stairs now these stairs that you walk down from they're open ones
So they're like around like the side of the building essentially dealing down to the dogs where like the warships are essentially docked
Uh, so you can see yourself like walking towards these warships
Okay
So what what is what is your plan
Here
I'm gonna go down there and I'm gonna be like hey somehow the guards
But all the prisoners got loose their causing chaos upstairs
Like I'm gonna try to find somebody okay, uh, can you give me another disguise roll one do 20
You know what I'm gonna make a list and check just in case
No, you see strictly uh, he
The guy that you approach essentially is like in this armor that you recognize from before on spare cliff
Uh, and he turns back in new looks at you and he pulls out like his enforcer and he goes
Stop right there
Remove that helmet
That's your name
How close is the
He's I mean you're literally approaching these maybe like five to ten feet away
Why I need to make sure he's like within five feet
He's not that close you can't reach him just like that yeah, you will have to move a bit and then
Um, and there's only one dude around us
Well near like the dogs you only see this one guy, but maybe the commotion will make more guards show up or something
Deben's
How you deal with them eventually okay
So
I'm going to he's within you said
10 to 15 feet so I'm gonna have to
I'm gonna take my helmet off
Throw it at him and while I threw it at him run at him with the pan black
Okay, uh you
Start to walk closer with like taking the helmet off slowly take it off throw it at him. Can you make a roll attack roll any any attack
With the advantage. Yeah, he's not expecting that so just
Just like roll the skeleton with yeah
Yeah, you know, that works a 17 will head
You bump the helmet
Uh onto his head he kind of gets like disoriented now you can hit him twice with the
Advantage with the skillet yeah
Oh shit
Roll critical
Oh
See the damage is oh my god you rolled eight both times so it's gonna be
Uh
But what did we decide first one is always eight like one of them is a max damage ray
It's one max one times roll so if you roll it should just roll normal damage and at the maximum
Okay, so
That's
To uh
I'm gonna say add six right so 11 and six is
17 17 damage rolled another
Well, this one's this was missing
Uh the first one hits him right in the head as you see like the armor kind of like gets like
bruised from
The side as the color kind of like
Gets off the armor like the blue paint kind of ropes off the armor and he turns around and looks at you and he goes
Right then we're taking you win and he uh kind of like banks onto the war machine
Uh
All right, uh, I think it's a good time
Yeah, it's gonna it's gonna use his action to just like call in reinforcements um
Okay, let's shift to what was happening before um, okay
Bad piece in mouth is you're still jumping roof to roof to roof to roof and uh
Was the head 22 hits right let me see 24 24 hits right
I'm teased
I was spotted
That was the perception for you
Yeah
Yeah, but you can't you like
There was stealth from the people that were there
From the above point he has advantage to look into
What is happening
What was your base roll?
No, no you don't it's from the sky you don't see it you just feel like this laser like hit you with the back
And it's 18 damage
What was your base roll for stealth?
19 19
hero old
A 17 I mean he's not gonna spot you, but then he's gonna spot malphous. It's gonna be the same thing
I had a 26 or my
You know the base the base you know what I'm gonna roll with advantage
You know what sure
What you want that my base was 18
That's fine. That's fine. I'm gonna roll it again because I said with the advantage
Uh
There you go see now he's watching
Okay, who are 120 plus oh
I was looking at the wrong one. Okay, so his
His was 17 I mean sure, but he's gonna be following Warren if you're following
Laura he's gonna spot you that's what I'm saying
What do you mean stealth how stealth are you in a open road at one point the fucking houses are ending. Okay, Jesus right
We look like he's not he's not in the fucking space. He's not in space
Uh
All right, what what are you doing are you following? Voro or not?
Yes, no good you're following. Voro and
stealthily so you're not following a Voro he's fucking on a car man
How far you could you follow stealthily
We're months. Oh my god
So how stealth works then
Can be super fast and stealth
We can I don't think so
You can move full movement that's not what I'm asking. It's just like the speed
I mean I know what they they stealthily attached themselves to his car
But he left away before it's like if you if they arrived and attached themselves with the car beforehand and that would make sense
That's what I wanted to do, but you said the car was surrounded by people and it wouldn't be possible. Yeah, I didn't
Yeah, so
Some things are not possible logistics
Yeah
I'm just saying
No, you can't follow the car show how how that that's what I'm asking you were jumping roof from roof in the market
Sure, but at one point this just like a straight road headed to the mansion. There's nothing you can hide inside right
It's just empty lots
I mean sure, but it's not gonna hide fucking mouthless
Well, they're not we mouthless can be okay, that's mouthless is pro so you you're just saying fuck mouthless
All right, I see what you're doing 24 hits your mouth, right
Come on, I gotta move this alone. What is you just a you following world or not? That's that's what I'm asking
And I'm gonna go ahead with whatever's happening
Yes, we're following it
Yeah, okay, you're following okay, he's gonna shoot you down
From the sky who's taking the 80 damage. I chose that teased you have to take it
I didn't choose that is it's a roll of faith man. I can't do it
Oh, I thought you said 80 like what the fuck now 18 18 Jesus Christ 18 is like a fucking new cool. What do you mean?
Why
I think a reaction
Uh, using a spell slot
A double for use okay, go ahead
Which is your spell slot essentially?
So I don't know why you said that yeah
What's your reaction? What do you want to do with your okay shield? Uh, I mean you don't see it coming but sure you know why not
How much is your AC now 24
It's going to be three 24 was the attack or was 24? It's going ahead anywhere. It was yeah
I mean I can send you a screenshot
24 yeah one one D20 plus eight
It's not missile
It's just laser. I don't know if you can oh you know what sure why not roll
But then you don't have to use shield don't use shield you can use this like
Okay
It's a talk
If I get the max roll
Uh-huh like that's not a max roll 13
Uh, what was the damage 18? Okay, as the like laser like literally just
Shoots you out of like in middle as you're jumping from the roof to the ground. It shoots you down
Uh, and you try to block it. It just doesn't matter. It just fucking shoots you down and you take
Uh five damage
Where are you?
Where are you? I don't see you okay there you are
Uh
Malphus you see
The laser kind of like drilling into malphus like a green laser just
blasting him
Out of the air and you see like this shadow approaching from the sky
On the ground and
Do you want to stay or you want to follow or
Is it man's rule numbers right now like what
soldier wise
Is it more manageable if we were to fight now than before when all of them were like searching
Well, no one's around except for that armor
So just a stew
Yeah, you two the armor guy
And his carriage
His carriage is very very far away he didn't spot you the armor spot you
Ah
How far which of these carriage was maybe like 60 feet
Oh, it's not fall. Don't you say that like very far. Oh, it's just 60. Yeah
What do you say about these? We're doing this
Do it
You want to stop world? What do you say do it explain?
You can't read your mind man
That's so I mean focus the armor we're just going to borrow
Get borrow
We're in this now
Okay, uh, I'm assuming you're headed to vora and
You
Baptiste are going to face off against the armor guy
Right yeah
All right, uh Roma let's switch back to you now
Uh, all right roba right now as soon as like the guard like kind of banged the
Worship you see a bunch of like Marines with their like
Inforce arrivals out and
Uh against you
This is this is where the minute he banged I am dipping like
Running running away like fucking Johnny Depp in the fucking like
You know the Miller group
I'm running up to where for that chaos is happening upstairs with all of these fuckers probably behind me. Okay
Uh, you can you can run
Uh, but I'll have to do at least like one roll to check if he should see or not
That's fine. Oh, and the 20 plus four
10 all right, all right, uh, he
No, that's me. That's me. That's me. I just selected his token. That's why
Uh, so 10 who does not hit as he like shoot you through like the
cage that's surrounding the
Stairs that lead lead leads up to
the main hallway
the
You run up
I'm gonna check for something
Okay
You run up you head inside the people
Uh, that were on the ship or worship and starting to now follow you up the roof
Uh, up the stairs
Uh, in line the boom boom, running up you enter in the like courtroom essentially and you see like still people like big chaos a lot of shit happening as you exit
Uh, you just see here like open fire going from the Marines that
We're following you and just just like put down everyone in the room
Uh, what are you doing? You're still running?
Oh, yeah, I'm running and being like Marines behind us
Yo, man, what did he do? What the fuck?
As uh, everyone you're just like shoving away it just gets shot down by the Marines
Uh, and you're running you're running you're running and uh
Immediately like the next
Okay, my question is there's 2000 cells
Mm-hmm. How many prisoners are in those cells? I mean, uh, let me check
They're like they're riding
They would have taken other guards guns
The minute they saw people shooting they would have either a shot back
Oh, hold you shit 1900 of those cells were
With with criminals and again, they're not like actual criminals some of them might be innocent
All right, so I'm gonna roll for
1d 1000 what is that?
So let's say like out of 80 in 1900 of them 600 were like just civilians uh, sorry 600 of them were like actual criminals
And the rest were like just civilians
So 600 of like actual criminal pirates and bandits and whatnot
That are currently riding destroying yes, yes, like you get what I'm saying like yes
So like they would have gotten guards guns the minute like 20 of them got shot
There's at least like a hole because there's probably what 20 or 30 people again
It's like it's it's a big place. It's not like everyone is at the place every time right so maybe
10 of them is in one room maybe 10 of them somewhere else and so on. It's a big place
They're pretty spent prayer to part what I'm
Mm-hmm
But what I'm saying though is I'm running towards like the exit where most of the prisoners would be running to
So like I'm going
Like the bridges are up
The riots are going on the bridges are up. There's no way to get out
So so you just made my job easier there's 686 hard and criminals
But not harder the a gun to a head is is that it's it's a
Shooting range essentially which is right in front of them
But they what I'm saying though is they're causing like everybody's riding yeah trying to get free
so like
There couldn't have been that many guards for it's not the guards is the Marines with the armor and the guns
It's not it's not like it's laser guns and it only have to reload they don't have to do anything just fucking shoot shoot shoot shoot shoot
But you're telling me none of these like
Didn't the other guards have guns or they just had spears
They had spears and guns, but there were guards and normal Marines
All the warship Marines are from Boros side that he brought in
So these are different people
That's what I'm saying like how many people are chasing you're telling me add a 686
Priminals like even if there's like
20 Marines like after you people it's still like it's pretty clear people with guns when
But if they're gonna bet that's what I'm trying to say like
In a prison in a prisoner right they're killing fucking everybody like the prisoners like they're like
86 of them were were criminals. They're gonna be
Yeah
You mean like costages
Yeah, they would have taken the hostages your tummy. I mean like it said it doesn't matter. They just shooting everyone down
It's borrow he doesn't give a shit
It's not not worth men
He's just gonna chalk it up to you know criminals going wild and that's it
No one knows what's happening
So it's just once I did you run out. It's fine. You're safe, but everyone else is dying
That's that's what I'm trying to figure out like yeah with these
686 people be able to stand or go up against 30
30 guards again like I'm saying it's not like the room that you entered in it's not like all 600 of them are in that same room right
They're spread apart. They're on different places doing different things
But these guards can just like yeah, these guards can just take over
But what I'm saying is so far support also again these like 30 guards are
Stationed here they can call in reinforcements. It's not just 30 you see as you arrive on the docs
You've seen like a bunch of worships. It's not just that one
But what I'm saying though like would these these 30
Again, it depends it depends on what happens and how it happens right?
I'm not saying that it's gonna go one way. I'm just saying that right now
They just follow you they see everyone yeah, they see everyone in their way. They're just gonna shoot and move on and just keep following
Exactly, I'm I'm fleeing like yeah, there's gotta be people that were working there
They're running for their safety like and I'm just blending in like running away like yeah
Writer
Yeah, can you roll stealth for me?
Oh
Actually, I do oh shit
Plus
Oh my god Jesus
Okay, as you're like running around
The Marine that you first hit immediately spots you and he's gonna just take a shot at you
Again
Uh, no, no, no, no, the Marine that you were fighting at the doc. I want that look downstairs. Yeah, okay
Are you stop
Okay
As soon as like the bullets not the bullets the laser leaves
The rifle and it's right in front of you. It just goes through you and you feel a hand on your shoulder
and
the next thing you see is just
You dropping down in the floor as you see the the layers of the ground change change change change
And you just drop down into the lower level essentially the basement in a room
uh, like completely uh
Like open like uh sell essentially
And uh, I'm gonna leave it here and we'll figure out what the fuck happened
Like
Okay, perfect essentially
What happened like from your perspective what you saw is the guy look at you is shout it
Hey, you stop. He shot at you. You saw the laser, but it just went straight through you as you like start to
Immediately go down and you see like the layers of the floor as you like going through the floor
As you just drop down in one of the
cells in the other place with like the door is a jar and you just felt a hand on your shoulder as that happened
That's it. I'm gonna leave it there
Okay, um
Baptist uh
And mouth is uh on your end
Baptist you see the
armor
Land right in front of you this armor seems different from the other one. Let me see if I can find picture
That's the other one we program
What
reprogramming reprogramming the armor what
That was a whole thing for bot before oh
Yeah
Let me see because it took the flight upgrade
marine armor
Yeah, this armor that you see in front of him is like
The visor inside of the wiser you see like glowing blue eyes on like the center of the helmet
You see the symbols of marines on the shoulders of the armor you see the symbol of marines the chest piece is
Completely white and in the center you see the symbol of marines and on the legs you see like the armor plates are way thicker
Then before this armor guy looks very tall maybe like
8 to 9 feet tall
And he just lands right in front of you and just starts walking
And he just stops
Uh as you get up
And mouth is you are chasing morrow what are you doing
I'm going to land on the roof of the car. Okay. You land on the roof of the car. That's it. It's your all you're done
Well for now
He is going to maybe like punch through the roof
Uh, let me see then
120 plus
Let's see if that hits
Okay, I'm gonna use his hockey point to add plus three to this 19
What the fuck now probably to the switch
Did it hit you think
Uh, you see like this armored hand just fist like the black fist coming through
The roof of the thing that you landed on just hits you square it in the chest as you fly up and land
On the side of the road and you just
Here like this kick that just throws the door of the vehicle like far away as
Moral this is the first time you're seeing him steps out
I knew you show up of course
Now where is your captain
So you will be bored
And who might you be oh
You're the navigator
Come on get up
Why do you raise that death?
Yeah
Oh you're the navigator
I'm gonna enjoy beating you to shit and then throwing you in front of your captain
Get up
And I'm gonna leave all of this here and we're gonna continue next time. It's literally 12
It's exactly 12 for me
What this fuck was this session
I don't know I asked that piece and Roma. I don't know what happened
Um
Hey look
Yeah, should actually like real fast one one place is having like a fucking full on riot and the other place
Just expose yourself like last time
Good old days
Oh, I didn't expose myself. I just made my mind. You basically did you basically said oh yeah, this is us
Hey, call the boss
Yeah
The fuck is the worst supposed to think who here is
Uh, honestly from like Roma's perspective. It's pretty pretty fine
You're gonna meet someone that you haven't met in a long time and I
I don't know if you guys figured out yet or not
And Malfa doesn't know what you guys should
Oh, maybe just forgot it's red or saffery. Yeah
It's red or saffery
Why would it be red or saffery? They don't have that power
What power?
The power that fucking lasers
No
You
Do you guys remember or not? I don't I don't know if you remember
That's what power you're being very big right now
I'm not I'm not being very big like there's only one power that can let you like
Pass through shit and you only know the one person that has that power
Oh, yeah, I know that's what's your name
Okay, six folds dude. Yeah, yeah with uh
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you figured out through what
Like
The floor nobody's passing through the floor
Oh shit. Oh Andy touch me. I got you
Yeah, you felt the shoulder touch and then you pass through the floor
How more clear do I have to be?
I just I just figured out we're circling fucking whale were god damn. Yeah, I got you. Yeah
What happened
You you you don't know because it's from their like sixfold part or like
Spiritclips is from Spiritclips essentially
So you don't know but um basically they used to they used to be with us and then went away with uh
Bestie senior no no no I know sir car will what
You know sir again well
It's not either siricus power. It's not it's not whales power
It's not it's not sir again well that's your it's wine is that's here yeah
That's what I've been trying to tell you
Yeah
So that means that means saplings should be here because you know I mean you have to figure it out
If she's here
So we'll pick it up
Bob could actually be in this fight
He sees the commotion and then get her let's do it. Yeah
Always Bob going
I mean he might hear the commotion
Yeah, you might hear the commotion
No, what's gonna happen is I told Lou if anything happens
It's a perfect this yeah
Go through dimension
I'll just go through the mentions
I am not sure if Lou's gonna make it back I mean he can he can stelt his way to the mansion or whatever sure
We'll see we'll see I'll do some I'll do some rolls we'll see
They're gonna suspect you dog
I mean they don't have a dog in the house
It's just a wild fox also it's like he's he's pretty small he can sneak by I'm pretty sure
You kill my dog
I'm not gonna kill you
I'm not evil I'm not evil I didn't fucking kill Bob but do you think I'm gonna kill a dog
Dog comes above Bob if you know
I can't wait
Yeah
But these red ones get me killed
Yeah, you I might kill you first
Well, I'm sorry I have I have a backup character so yeah no no no no we're not doing that
I spent a way too much time on you and your fucking sister to do you to get you killed all right
But other than that whatever decisions you make I can't help with that
I had planned for Linus to be
at the
Court anyway, I just I was waiting for a moment to bring him up, but I guess the moment came
Escalated is yeah, I mean you would have eventually found Linus anyway regardless
It's just cooler this way
That's the one we're to do
I mean it's fine. It's fine. It's I's up to you. I'm here to facilitate your craziness
It's my job to figure it out
As long as you make it out of this fight with the mean fucking guy
Apparently alive
And it's fine
Hey, I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna warn you
You can't fight him alone
I'm just gonna tell you straight up you can't fight him
So Baptiste
You gotta you gotta speed up your shit bro
I
Can't just get to Baptiste again. I mean yeah, you can just fucking fly over
Yeah, that was big mouth is half has the 60 feet I know so only he could take the catch up to the carriage
Yeah, no no no no, this helps if you can switch
Yeah, you're like tap tap out. I'm going to that guy you fight him
This is your target
You won't but this wait a second. I'll go get him. I go get him. I just give you a sec
No, you're not over here because we're all can't catch you we double-team this guy real quick and then just turn
Oh, I'm not so sure everybody can catch you. I wouldn't say that
He
He has so room and
I know I think he has legendary reactions to yeah
He has legendary actions and reactions. I really fucked them with the legendary actions literally on the first fight
I'm sorry, please
I could no wish look melvin he has to fight will and Sarah's
And then turn around and fight right after yeah, no rest
Uh, that's pretty brutal
I mean to be fair like these are like kind of the main characters of the campaign. So it fits
The six falls and like one of the main antagonist
essentially
We're getting rid of your antagonist today. Oh, we'll see. I don't think you can but we'll see
I don't think you two can I think Bob might have been able to he has a way too much dps
That's why he can probably yeah
Yeah, he's kind of like you know, I do
I still do circle down single will
This damage yeah, I mean you're more for like support and that stuff
Well, they will figure it out
Roman Linus is journey is going to be funny
So we'll see what happens
All right
I'm gonna be funny a shit. I'm gonna be funny a shit
We'll see the first interaction